Film Courage: Travis what
is your ideal screenwriting
life? Travis Seppala, Author/Screenwriter:
Well I moved to Los Angeles to try and get
into tv writing so I've been writing features much
longer so I have more experience with that but tv
writing is where I want to be at. You know get the
stories of working with other people's characters
is a fun challenge rather than just being god
all the time with your own stuff so I thought
that's probably my best place to be would be TV
writing plus I write so fast pumping out what like
six-seven scripts a year so tv writing. They
need to have that speed to get material out in
time for production. Film Courage: So that would
be appealing to you, to be in a writer's world for
like what is it 15 hours a day sometimes? Travis:
Getting to especially bouncing ideas off of other
people too when you're writing features you're
just kind of by yourself at your computer and
in a writer's room you've got between four and
ten other people that we're all bouncing ideas
off each other to figure out the best possible
story for the show so have you envisioned that
do you have like this dream board or is there
something where you're like you know what
this is this is what my ideal life looks like
and i need to create that you know i have never
done a dream board i've seen it i've seen it
in shows and movies where characters have that
sort of thing but i've never done it for myself
i just kind of uh keep you know my board of what
what stuff i'm writing right now you know keeping
track of where i need to be and deadlines and all
that stuff but i've never really made an official
visual element of of where i want to be you know
maybe i should that would be there you
go yeah something to look at you know
so have you submitted uh spec scripts to tv
shows um yeah uh you know i got a manager
starting last year and so it was at the very end
of staffing season though so she'll just only
get me able you know a couple of read uh piles um
this year staffing season's not started quite yet
they're doing you know filming the pilots right
now as we speak so i'm already got on a couple of
people's read lists uh to consider me for staffing
so fingers crossed so that works out well um and
then you know obviously if i see any assignments
you know on any of like the the different
screenwriting boards you know where producers
are looking for something specific you know
you send them a spec so they can see if if your
style works with what they need to hire for so
an ideal show to write for or shows i'm a big fan
of anything superhero related so like the flash
supergirl uh superman and lois that's gonna be
coming out this fall uh arrow unfortunately is
leaving however they're going to be doing the
spin-off of arrow and the canaries and i'm all on
board with that um the dc network where they've
got you know the titans and uh doom patrol and
so like anything with superheroes i'm on board
with um any kind of like cool sci-fi stuff um
you know like a manifest that's on is is is fun
um i like a lot of anything with superheroes
or sci-fi i'm on board with uh i know a lot of
people watch the hbo stuff i feel like i'm the
only person in hollywood who doesn't have hbo so i
haven't seen game of thrones or succession or any
of these big things i definitely need to be seeing
put that on the dream board yeah exactly you know
for 14 was it 14 bucks a month or something like
that right right yeah there you go manifested what
is about the superhero genre that you're attracted
to um i feel okay so i've never been a fan of like
the super serious um stories where it's like
the slice of life type stuff because i'm
already living life i don't have superpowers i'm
a superman fanatic because he gets to do so much
cool stuff and at the end of the day still is a
person with his wife and has a job and all this
stuff you know so um i think it's a big thing
of living the fantasy and and being able to
live within the fantasy while you're writing
those types of characters and situations um
and even watching it you know you're only watching
for 45 minutes plus commercials that you're taking
away to some other place you have to think about
your life while you're watching the flash you
know rescue iris from girlagrad or something you
know telepathic gorillas people flying and running
around super speed like we don't have that in
our life so uh i feel like that appeals to me
because i like nobody wants to live in their life
24 7. you know that's why halloween is a big thing
you know you get to be someone else for a night
well you get to be somebody else while you're
watching the show living vicariously through them
or writing those type of characters uh you know
imagining because i feel i feel like most writers
probably imagine themselves in the characters
that they're writing and then kind of living
vicariously for that amount of time you know
because like you gotta figure out okay what would
they do what would i do how is that different um
so yeah i i've always wanted to have super powers
so i feel like that's my my in there uh big comic
book fan i have a huge superman collection um i
ever since i was like six years old i got my first
superman comic book and i've been obsessed
ever since then i have like over 3000
pieces of superman memorabilia so yeah i'm i'm
obsessed with it oh my goodness uh so yeah that's
a long answer for why i like superhero stuff
but now that's interesting because while we were
setting up we were just talking about sort of the
24-hour news cycle and it seems like we're just
fed so much bad news all the time all the time
that it must be nice to to have that difference
right so you know why why do i want to hear about
all the terrible things going on in the world
when i can watch okay terrible thing wearing in
the city that this guy in tights is going to fix
you know yeah exactly right and not spandex
yeah i don't change the costume so much now
you know it used to be like it used to be
spandex though you know you watched like uh
superman you know from back in george
reeves days you know in the 30s and 40s like
or the 40s and and he was obviously wearing
spandex and now it's like this weird
like under armour stuff where you can see like all
the designs throughout the whole costume and stuff
so maybe it's more aerodynamic i don't
know right it's breathable yeah yeah
you grew up in michigan yeah uh monroe
it's a small town it's here okay uh little
general motors yeah well so detroit is like up
here and then i'm down here so you know you go
up a little you go out to here to the lansing you
know and uh down here you got ohio so i'm like
right at the border between michigan and ohio
uh about 30 minutes south because you know we
don't we don't do miles in michigan it's it's how
long the distance is to drive there is in minutes
or hours that's true yeah so we drive about 30
minutes north to get to detroit or 30 minutes
south to get to delete ohio so interesting
okay uh small towns maybe population like 350
000 so it's not like a tiny tiny town but it's
definitely much not a city size and were there
writers people that you could emulate or was
this more based on general motors and sort
of lee iacocca yes considered yeah most of the
stuff so in well because we're not even far nor
far enough to detroit to have a lot of general
motors workers so in monroe we have the edison
power plant and they're them and then um what's it
called i don't remember the name of it there's a
glass factory that also was like the two of them
were like the two main employers in my town uh
power plant the glass place we also are the home
of uh lazy boy chairs they have nice their world
corporate office is there in monroe as well um so
they have like you know plenty of people working
there um that's yeah those are pretty much the
main employers in in that town so uh but i grew
up with with parents who are teachers so they were
you know working in the school districts and stuff
oh so they fostered a love of books oh yeah
um and writing even like my mom's biggest
punishment for us as kids uh was writing by
hand like so let's say we said a swear word
she would make us look up the definition of the
swear word in the in the dictionary and then write
the definition by hand like between 50 to 100
times depending on the severity of the curse word
and that was her primary form of punishment for
us was having to hand write things or like if we
did something wrong with dude like the you know
you see on the simpsons when he's writing on the
chalkboard like i will not blah blah blah you have
to do that sort of thing so i still have terrible
handwriting though so she couldn't read what i was
writing but you know uh you would think that my
handwriting would improve after writing the same
thing four thousand times in an hour but yeah not
so much so then you never viewed it as punishment
it sounds like you well there was something you
found you know it kind of started you know so
i'm already writing stuff i'm like well as long
as i'm having to write i'm also writing my own
stuff too and i you know i won my first uh short
story contest when kindergarten uh wrote like a is
the story was uh how daddy tried to catch the bat
uh we seemed to get a bat would get into the
house every winter and me and my dad would have
to be the ones to take because my sister and my
mom were terrified of bats you know so we would
go down there with like uh tennis racket and a
fishing net you know and like trap it between it
take it outside and stuff like that oh nice catch
and release yeah um so we did that uh you know i i
wrote that like i said i was like kindergarten's
like five six years old and stuff wrote that
um won a contest in that same contest it was
called the young authors competition and it was
in all all elementary schools and junior high
in high schools and in the area basically had
you know one person per grade got sent
there and i got sent there like six times i
did like kindergarten like third grade fifth grade
a couple times in high school you know so always
been writing since forever basically when you told
them that you wanted to come to los angeles to be
a tv writer what was their impression uh it kind
of mixed um you know because there's obviously
no guarantee writing is like the hardest thing to
make money at you know so um growing up even like
when i you know wanted to do something in the arts
you know because i used to sing choirs and stuff
too when i was growing up so like i want to be a
singer for a while i want to be a writer be a poet
you know um all this other stuff so they're like
well you know though that's great but you need
to wait find a way to make money too you know so
um because like i i've even mentioned in my book
how hard it is to be like there's a statistic in
the book that it's actually there are more working
football players in the nfl than there are working
writers in the wga so it's hugely you know hard to
get into because there's so many people doing it
and so many talented people doing it too you know
so you could be an amazing writer in your hometown
and you're just one of a number out here in l.a
i think you've said that it happened one night is
one of your favorite films yeah that's my favorite
oh it is yeah um i love that movie and i feel like
even though it was you know came out in the 30s
i feel like the the dialogue on it like there's a
few quirky things you know that no one would ever
say nowadays that was like slang for for that
time but for the most part the story and a lot
of the dialogue could even still come out today i
feel like and still be a viable thing you'd have
to change you know some of the what they consider
risque things you know and update it and stuff but
i i think it's fantastic and you know the acting
in it is great and yeah i love i think it's like
the one flawless and a lot of people think uh
we'll say casablanca as like their flawless movie
casalong is great but i i'm a big big fan of it
happened one night so it's claudette colbert and
um not uh clark gabriel park park okay and so
he's this journalist and she's like this wealthy
yeah she's like an heiress like a paris
hilton type of person back then you know
and her dad wants her to marry you know it's her
person the person she wants to marry he doesn't
like and so she he's like willing to they want
to like disown her and stuff so she runs away to
go and marry the guy she wants to marry and so
the dad puts out basically like a bounty on his
own daughter to find you know if you can bring
her back to me like you'll get so much money
and uh this reporter who's an out-of-work
reporter who's not on good terms with his boss
accidentally sees her like on a bus they end
up riding the bus together and he kind of like
ends up trailing her and makes the deal with her
that he won't turn her in for the money if she
gives him the exclusive on everything that's
happening so they end up going cross-country
together with him taking notes and of course they
slowly fall in love along the way even though
they start off you know despising each other like
most romances seem to do in movies don't like
each other when you meet but by the end you're in
love so uh yeah yeah i think it's a fantastic film
travis when did you move to los angeles and why
2016 uh august 26th yeah i've only been out here
a couple years wow okay um and again because i
wanted to get into television writing like you can
write features anywhere but if you want to do tv
you got to be out here where the rooms are um you
know they might film in other places you know like
vancouver is a big place to film because of all
the film incentives that they have you know like
tax budget tax breaks and stuff like that uh but
the rooms are all still out here in los angeles
there's a couple in new york but mostly out here
um so since i wanted to do tv writing i kind of
had to be where the rooms are and moved out here
uh to do that and what were you doing prior
to 2016 what was life like uh for travis so i
moved here from virginia beach um so i like i'm
originally from michigan i moved from michigan
to virginia in 2011. uh to be a massage therapist
yeah i've done a lot of jobs in my life so i moved
there to be a massage therapist did that for a
few years kind of got burned out on it um and
then was working as a dispatcher for an alarm
security company oh but also yeah and but still
writing on on the side you know for for writing
so like i got hired when i was working there
got hired to write eight episodes of a sci-fi
series in the uk that to the best of my knowledge
still has not come out and that was you know years
ago now um and wrote like a bunch of different
features for like independent producers all around
the country like a lot of people when i tell
them out here that oh yeah i was getting jobs in
virginia and they're like oh well that's different
out here no i was writing for hollywood producers
like low budget hollywood producers from virginia
uh you know so i was still doing the writing but
doing all these other odd jobs on the side as well
and did you fly out or drive i drove uh yeah
so i actually took me a couple days to get
out here because i drove from virginia beach i
drove up to michigan so i could see my parents
because i hadn't seen them in a couple years
since i had moved um i still haven't seen my
sister even since when was the last time i saw
naoka uh like 2011 i think like i think it was
like the first year i had moved away and i came
back for christmas that's the last time i even
see my sister so hopefully she comes up to my
wedding later this year do you want to give her an
invitation right now or well she she's okay she's
she's one of my best men basically she's nice i
have grooms people you know there we go yeah so i
had to have my sister in there but yeah so i moved
so when i was moving i drove up to michigan spent
like a day or so with my parents uh and then drove
the rest of the way out here like i made a couple
stops like overnight because it's too far to drive
in one thing so i think i stopped in kansas city
and then a second stop in phoenix where my cousin
lives and hung out with him for a day and then got
out here and then had my first hollywood meeting
like two days after i arrived so with a manager it
didn't go so well uh unfortunately um but you know
his first meeting can't really expect because i
didn't know what to do at my first meeting all my
experience before then was either meetings
on the phone or via email you know so
i feel like i babbled like i did like i'm doing
now well i'm actually maybe just leaving out names
to protect the innocent or not so innocent what
what was what do you think went poorly about it um
the fact that i didn't really know how to conduct
a meeting uh first off so i was kind of going off
on various tangents on all my various projects
uh it was the manager so they want to know like
your best thing and what you do um not everything
you've ever written kind of thing you know and so
i was sitting there going oh i've written this
horror and i've written this sci-fi and i've
written this thing for tv and movies and blah blah
and it's like when you get done so many things you
don't want to mention all those things because
nobody cares at a certain point you know like
um especially when things aren't being produced
so uh that's my the one advice i probably break
my own advice often enough and stuff is don't tell
everyone when you're when you're having a meeting
with the manager don't tell them every single
thing up front you know it's only like in dates
yeah oh i've had some bad days where i've done
that for sure um yeah okay so like you're going
on so like going off way too f onto way too many
tangents telling wait like over sharing like crazy
um did not go well and then not really knowing
i guess like where you fit in the industry um
is kind of hurtful uh because you want like
there's so many people out there who want to do
all these other things you go to like a
networking thing and you're people who are like
8 000 hyphenates oh i'm a writer director
producer art director blah blah you know or
people who are like oh yeah i can write everything
i write drama and horror and comedy no you don't
you write like one thing really well you might be
interested in writing those things you might even
have scripts and other things but there's no way
you write equally well across the board in every
genre it's just not happening do you think it was
just being eager and maybe you know the industry
hadn't beaten you down and so you didn't know and
you were just being innocently eager um possibly
um but i feel like again that kind of goes with
like a naivete about how the industry really works
um you know having again not having had any
in-person time like face-to-face with with
hollywood industry folks it was just you know
sending out an email or being on the phone with
somebody um reading screenwriting books and
stuff you know they usually tell you like
how to write the scripts there's not really
a lot of business oriented books out there so
um you don't really learn how to conduct a meeting
very well unless you're actually doing it because
you can have all the theory on it you want
but until you're face to face with somebody
uh knowing how you're gonna behave with
them totally different when you finished
that meeting did you already have an intuition
about this didn't go well yeah kind of um kind
of like when you go for an interview for a job you
kind of have an idea if it went well or not right
but you know i've had meetings with producers too
where i have no clue how it went when i walked out
because they're so straight faced they're not
giving anything away and then like so you could
think you did terribly and then they call you
the next day want you to come and write their
thing you know so it's hard to gauge usually but
i feel like in that particular case i kind of
knew that it wasn't going to go the way
i wanted it to go when i walked out so
when they start when they start checking their
watch or their phone and stuff part way through
the meeting you know that's not a good thing with
the phone thing it might just be typical etiquette
these days with with people you know being glued
to their communication but when you left that
meeting what was your feeling about being in l.a
you'd been here what two days yeah i had gotten
here sunday night of that week and the interview
the meeting with her was tuesday morning so yeah
like a day and a half maybe um i know when i was
moving i hear people were telling me about like
all the traffic and i'm going to be sitting on the
freeway forever but i'm so against i'm originally
from detroit area like nobody lives in detroit
but people work there you know so it's like
the commute that way so the only difference
is here it's much shorter distances in the
traffic so um but the weather is fantastic i
hate snow which is why i wanted to get out of
michigan to begin with and the snow followed
me to virginia because a friend of mine who
lives in in virginia where i moved to told me
oh there's no snow here ever like first year
i moved there blizzard of like 13 inches every
year i lived there it was at least eight inches
out here i have not a single day
of snow it's fantastic i love it
so then you you still had your hopes up or
did you oh absolutely i you i'm not one to
easily get down especially knowing like i
said how hard it is anyway so um it's just
sticking notch on the belt kind of thing oh here's
another no okay moving on let's you can't just let
the nose get to you otherwise like you will drop
out of this business like immediately like even
like spielberg is even getting no's
and he's steven spielberg you know
you're always going to get the nose and because
you can't uh you can't appease everybody's tastes
and everything you know so like i've had i've had
scripts that in one contest doesn't even get the
quarterfinals another one will be a semi-finalist
give my top two or something like that you have
people when having getting notes on scripts where
one person will love this scene and talk about
how amazing the scene is the next person's like
oh this is a terrible scene it needs to change
it's like they're talking about the exact same
thing and one person loves it one person hates it
so you know you can't really base your feelings
on the industry and one person's opinion is
you know you kind of got to keep keep going and
keep trying and getting your stuff out there
when did you start calling yourself a screenwriter
probably my second or third script like my first
script it was kind of you know i was writing
about like a personal experience and i was just
kind of it was almost like therapy for me at
the time and so then probably my second script
i was an aspiring screenwriter like i was like
oh this is fun i want to do this and i probably
got my third maybe fourth script is when i was
like oh yeah i'm a screenwriter i'm not getting
paid yet but i'm a screenwriter like this is where
i'm going uh and then my fifth script was a paid
script so i was like i already made it come true
awesome it wasn't very big paid because it was a
small like local person i think it got
paid like 500 bucks or something like that
um to write a feature uh that never got made so
but yeah i probably by third or fourth script is
when i went from being an aspiring experiencer
like yes this is what i'm doing with my life
did someone say to you don't call yourself an
aspiring writer oh you will always get haters who
say like if you're not making money at it you
shouldn't call yourself a screenwriter like uh you
know they're like oh you wouldn't call yourself
a plumber because you fixed your own toilet well
i'm still writing screenplays and you know i'm
not doing it just for myself i'm still trying to
get my stuff out into the world whether it's being
paid or not because you know when writing a spec
script you're not paid for writing that spec so
are you not a screenwriter because it hasn't sold
yet like you still wrote the thing it takes time
effort energy heart blood soul everything goes
into these scripts you know so you're absolutely
if you're if you're actually doing the work you're
absolutely a screenwriter um i feel like the
only way that you're not is if you're someone who
says you're a screenwriter and aren't doing any
work towards it i've met people who are like i'm
a screenwriter okay great what have you worked on
oh well i haven't read anything yet but i want to
be welcome to los angeles exactly right yeah uh i
i heard um you know on twitter i follow a lot of
show runners and and stuff like that and there was
a show runner i'm trying to remember who it was
now that it was like a couple weeks ago that they
met someone at a party um they knew who she was
and what what show she was on and they're like oh
well you know i would love to write on your show
that it's fantastic and they had built a rapport
before we brought it up which is good um and then
she said okay well sure send me over a sample
he didn't have any samples he had not written
a single thing but he's telling her how much he
wants to write for her show wow and yeah it's like
why why are you bringing that up if you don't have
anything to to show and prove yourself you know
to them um because like oh well in that case i
want to go and play you know baseball but i don't
have the experience on it i want to so as soon
as you're doing the work you're a screenwriter
okay that makes sense and so what i was also
wondering is did did you feel like you held
yourself back because you were calling yourself
for i think after your second script and aspiring
right i don't think i was holding myself back
i think it was uh i think it was more of like
i didn't have the nerve to call myself that yet
because i was so inexperienced um and i wasn't
sure if that's what i wanted to do and be with
you know have as my career it was just something
at the time was for fun because like like i said
the first script i wrote is like a therapy for a
situation i was in at the time my second script i
wrote a superman script not knowing that you can't
write you know material because of like copyright
infringements and stuff like that i didn't know
that it was a thing yet at that time i was in
my like early 20s so didn't really know that you
couldn't write a superman script and send it out
there but it was fun and figured out what doesn't
doesn't work in the writing especially for action
sequences and um but then by my my third and
fourth thing like i said i was starting to write
my own original material at that point then and
that's when i became a screenwriter as
opposed to just somebody who has fun doing it
how do you motivate yourself to write every
day so this is a discussion i've had with
other writers because i'm very prolific and that
i write like i said lots of material a year and i
write every day if i can help it um occasionally
i can't because i've got like too many chores and
errands to have to run where i can't find time
to sit there um but i'm of the belief that if you
if you want to be a writer you need to actually
be writing um so i don't need motivation i just
need to get my butt in the seat and do the
work um might not always be fantastic stuff
than pumping out if you know if i'm sitting there
just to write just to get the pages out but um the
act of writing is something that you need to do
every single day or as frequently as you can in
order to keep doing it because if you write just
when you're motivated to write like if you're not
motivated to write for like months at a time
you're not going to get any material written
and if you especially since i want to do
tv writing like you can't just be like oh
sorry boss i don't i don't feel like writing my
episode today i'll give it to you next week if i
feel like it doesn't fly so you kind of have to
motivate it or not you can't just wait for the
muse to hit you have to you know force the muse
sometimes and and tell her okay get your wings
in here because i'm writing now it's time you
know so uh yeah i don't really go with needing to
motivate it's just i'm i have to write i'm writing
it's something i have to do it's not something i
always want to do because sometimes you're like oh
i would much rather go to the beach today and then
be sitting at my computer screen but you're not
going to get stuff done that way so i i don't need
the motivation to write i just i am the motivation
i write i'm a little writing machine basically so
stick me up for my computer pages are going to
get pumped out one interesting thing about like
having a day job is i found that that i always
want to be doing something else but then once
you have that free time i don't know if it's
fear or what it is then all of a sudden it's
like ah and then you find all these excuses do you
ever fall prey to that oh absolutely um because i
do have a day job unfortunately um so uh luckily
my day job i have plenty of down time at the day
job where i can do some writing you know there
i can't be in final draft at the work computer
but i can be you know like outlining in a notebook
or something like that you know to at least get
some ideas down to to fix issues i may have in
the script at home um but then yeah like i i am
not good at staying awake late like at all like
midnight i'm i'm out um so i get home from my
day job at like 10 30 at night i have enough time
to to walk the dog with my fiance and then watch
maybe an episode of tv and then i'm gone so i do
all my writing in the morning when i wake up i'm
up you know between eight and eight thirty every
morning uh pump out between two to four hours
worth of writing before i go to work every day
so and then on my days off i used to write a ton
uh but i was getting super stressed apparently
and so my fiance would have stopped that
she's like nope on your day's off you're
not writing sorry uh if you need to for a uh
like a deadline or something like that you know i
just had to do a rewrite um on a script feature of
mine that's going to be getting filmed in a couple
months and and so they had their their notes for
the final rewrite and they're like okay we need
to have this by this day so we can get it to our
actors and stuff so um i got to write on on those
days uh it's more of like one of those i get to
kind of scenarios i feel very bad if i went
a whole day and didn't write anything so
um because i just feel like i should be writing
you know it's to the point now where once you do
something it becomes habit you know what is it
like you do something for 30 days it becomes a
habit for you and you'll keep doing it so writing
every day i at this point it's it's not a oh i
feel like writing today it's i have to write i
can't do anything else until i get my pages done
so do you have this ritual in the morning where
you like get your coffee ready oh i don't drink
coffee well you're not oh you know i was force-fed
coffee as a child because it does the same thing
that as ritalin in young children because of
the difference in metabolism versus adults
so you know the in children they burn
through the caffeine much faster it
has like a ritalin type effect where it kind
of calms them down and ritalin when i was a kid
like gave me really bad stomach cramps and so
the doctor was like oh give him a cup of coffee
every morning and do the same thing so yeah
so i had to drink coffee every morning before
school from the age of six to the age of 16 and
i so i won't drink it now my fiance loves coffee
and i think it's gross okay i won't put it in
my mouth it's an expensive habit if you get the
right especially if you're going with starbucks
you know where you're dropping like four or five
bucks on a cup like you know um but yeah so i i
don't really do that but uh i definitely i wake up
um if sometimes i'll go work out like i'm trying
to do like the new year's resolution thing of
hitting the treadmill a couple times a week
sometimes i do it as many times as i need to
but not usually um so you know hit the treadmill
if i'm able if i have the energy to do it um
otherwise hit the computer i have a
really bad habit checking my email first
so i know i've heard many people say don't do that
like you know once like stephen king says don't
check your email until you've already done your
morning writing and then check your email later
on in the day i can't do that i have to i've
got too many things coming in from producers
newsletters of where like i want to read these
articles and stuff you know so i'll i'll set
aside the articles but at least got to go through
i'm also very organized in my email um most people
you know they'll have like their junk mail
just sitting there forever and have like 10
you look on their phone they've got 10 000 emails
that are unread yeah i go through meticulously and
i even have folders for every topic so i will
like move to so if it's a you know if it's a
on a certain movie that like i'm talking back like
right now i'm working on a web series and so if i
get an email from the producer for the web series
it goes to his folder and if i get something
that is from my fiance about our wedding plans
i'll move that to our wedding folder and i'll
you know so i only ever have in my inbox like at
most like 10 or 12 emails because i read things
and then file it away to where it goes and and
delete all my junk mail before i read anything
i need to read so that takes probably way too much
time to do all that and then i start writing once
i've done all my email and my and checking
like the social media briefly and um writing
probably start so i wake up at eight uh probably
start writing nine nine thirty depending on how
much junk mail there's a sift through uh and then
i'll write until about like 10 30 or 11 when we
gotta walk the dog then i'll make breakfast for my
me and my fiance and then usually have a working
breakfast eating there while i'm still typing away
pages till about like 11 maybe 12 and then take a
shower start getting ready for my day job and then
out the door by one so uh yeah so writing for like
i said between two to four hours a day every day
before going to work what's stephen king's logic
uh for not checking emails before writing that
it's just a time waste um and and it's something
that you can get carried away with as i just
proved i'm sitting there moving everything around
and checking everything and filing things away
it can get to the point where you know i all of a
sudden i've waited i've been sitting there for an
hour and a half and i haven't done anything that's
not email yet you know and um you know the the
writing needs to come first so i know that that's
what i should be doing i just can't seem to peel
myself away from my email and to save it for later
um i feel like i have to know all the things that
are going on especially with like i said the the
web series i'm working on like the producers in
in barcelona yeah so the time difference i have
like he sends me stuff i'm already asleep when he
sends me stuff so now i'm getting it and have to
respond and stuff like that so um yeah i think
i think that's the logic of don't check your
email to later like get your pages done first
at least someone even if you're gonna like let's
say you have the goal of writing okay i'm gonna
write 10 pages today okay write your first five
pages then when you need a break you check your
email and stuff then make sure you come back to
it you know so um or save it towards later
of the day because i could potentially just
you know check all my email at work at my day
job you know but i'm just obsessed i don't know
what it is well i think certain people have things
about like they need the house in somewhat of yeah
or there's like different things oh everyone has
some kind of procrastination tool for sure you
know like or need for order though i think
people need order sometimes don't you think
maybe i don't know i i know writers who
you know they they won't start writing
until their desk is exactly the way it needs
to be for the day and that could take them a
while cleaning stuff off putting their coffee
just so you know making sure the light's coming
through a certain angle and stuff like no just
write if you're gonna write start writing so
i don't know because i know i need
i should change my email to later on
but uh as of right now it's my procrastination
tool i wake up i check my email right so
what's the formula for a bad story i feel
like there's many ways that a story could
go bad um not picking the right character to
be the lead i've definitely have read scripts
where the lead character is much less interesting
than like a secondary character in the script
it's like why are you putting the focus here
um being completely plot driven to the point
where we don't really have characters what if the
whole story is just set piece after set piece and
we don't care about what's going on or who the
people are in the cool set pieces it can be as
cool as you want and still kind of fail because
there's not enough of a story there you know um
not uh not having any kind of connection i think
is probably the biggest the biggest bad thing
that you'll see in a script is you know having the
wrong character or not caring about the character
um i know that uh anti-heroes are like a big
thing nowadays you know like the joker movie
and and breaking bad the series let me know and
so a lot of people think you know because it used
to be that oh you have to like the character well
you don't necessarily have to like the character
no if anybody liked the character and
joker there's something wrong with them
um you know it's a great it's a good movie but
it's like if you can get on board with that
character doing those awful things there's nothing
wrong with you but the thing is you care about the
character right because you know they're they're
doing the bad things but like you're seeing
in addition to the bad stuff you're seeing
like the human side of the character
there's something that you can connect
to you know like taxi driver even which
again is a similar story to joker and
stuff they're doing the bad stuff but like
they've got humanistic things about them you know
that that connects you um where and like even
superhero movies you know like those quotes from
some famous directors that we won't throw under
the bus you know you know oh super hero movies you
know they're just like a roller coaster ride or
whatever he said it was it's like but you know if
like superhero movies done well you care about the
character like that's the thing that like marvel
does really well you know in in their movies is
that you care about the superheroes it's not just
this guy in an iron suit who can blow stuff up
with you know repulsor cannons or whatever
it's called like you care about him and his
interactions with other people around him and
his you know how he wants to solve the problem
um if it was just a faceless person in a thing
blowing stuff up there's no nothing there to care
about you know so that's probably the biggest
bad thing people do is not giving us something
to hold on to for the character do you think that
the level of empathy has improved like i'm forgive
me i i don't know much about the superheroes so
i'm hoping you can educate me on sure so let's
take christopher reeves as supe superman uh
in the end as you should okay all right so um
do you think that version of superman has evolved
in terms of some of the humanistic qualities they
give to him um so like our if we like we're to
compare that one with like some of the more recent
supermen um i feel i love okay i love christopher
superman i love henry cavill at superman they're
fantastic but they're very different superman
um the movies obviously the tone is much darker
in the new one than than the one in the 80s
different time yeah different things in the world
but there's still in each of them they still have
human traits like they're this alien from outer
space who has god-like powers but they were raised
as a person you know so they're not um superman
is his secret identity he's clark kent if you
think of the stuff because he was raised by
mom paul kent to be a good person long before he
even had the ability to knock over buildings and
you know carry kryptonite planet their
rocks mountains into the space you know
like like happened because in uh superman
returns you know brandon ralph's superman
which is a continuation but okay um i can go into
too much superman stuff but the point is they were
people they were humans and they were brought up
as good people from their parents before they had
the ability to do god-like things you know so
if they were just if it was just somebody who
was automatically born already had the superpowers
and because there are so in comic books um one
thing that dc used to do was the uh the elseworlds
stories and there's my favorite one is uh superman
red sun they're gonna have an animated version
of come out later this year i'm psyched for
um where he you know crash landed in um soviet
russia and he was basically raised as the superman
the ubermensch uh you know so he basically became
their weapon you know during like the the wars
and stuff and so uh it's it's a whole nurture
versus nature thing you know of of how he was
raised because his his humanity is much lower in
red sun than it ever was in the main continuity
because he was raised by mom paul kent over
here whereas over here he was you know raised by
you know soldiers and and the government and stuff
like that to be a weapon um i don't know where i'm
going with that but i don't know i think i think
you you've you've touched on it so we're trying to
it sounds like because of the timing of so the 80s
that the world was definitely a different place
you had fears and there were things looming but
it seems like today uh the intensity and then
hence the story is darker yeah so the tone is
darker but but he's even if you look at him as
a character though he still got raised by mom
paul kent so he still makes you know humanistic
choices even when he's fighting against zod you
know one thing that everybody in for the new
superman movie with henry cavill the people
didn't like him in man of steel was that he end up
killing zod at the end spoiler alert if you didn't
see it yet um they're like oh no superman would
never kill but the so it's a much darker thing but
it's he still made the choice to save human life
you know because that's the way he was raised
you know like his his own dad you know made him
not be superman basically to save other people
and stuff because it would oust him well in this
case he's doing whatever it takes to save those
people because he couldn't save people before so
and then going back to the christopher e version
he's you know doing whatever it takes to save the
people like putting himself in harm's way with
like the kryptonite and then having to go along
the missiles granted in the old one he got to fly
around the earth to save lois and reverse time
which our guy didn't get to do but uh he's still
making all of his choices based on a human quality
as opposed to a superman quality he's just a human
who gets to do the superman quality which is why i
say that superman it's not that clark kent is not
his superman here at any superman is clark kent's
secret identity do writers want to control their
story world and if so what should they accept as
out of their control so there's a couple different
schools of thought i guess that writers seem to
have um you've got writers who think that they
are god and all these characters must bow to
their whim because they're the ones telling the
story i'm kind of one of those writers there are
other writers who let the story tell itself where
they they you know basically sit back and they're
just like unraveling as the characters are coming
up with the ideas i find that the people in the
second group who are just letting the story tell
itself are also the ones who don't outline and
may get lost in the trenches along the way i'm a
serial outliner i will not start page one until
i have a bulletproof story i will do my outline
and then do a rewrite on the outline and do a
rewrite on the outline and until like the story
as as flawless as i can personally make it before
i even start writing the script and then i'm
just adding dialogue basically at that point
um so i have complete control over everything uh
things might change a little bit in the drafting
like if something doesn't work once i'm actually
writing out the longer version of it then i might
make some tweaks but for the most part it sticks
almost identical to my outline or the point where
i'm literally crossing off scenes on my outline as
soon as i finish typing it move on to the next one
whereas the people who don't outline and or let
the characters live their own lives they seem to
meander more in the story and as they're letting
it go wherever it wants to go well that's a very
good way to suddenly have like a 400 page script
in front of you and you know uh in that case i
feel like those people should are more geared
better towards novels you know where they can
go off and on these long tangents that don't
really connect to the story other than they're
still using the characters um so i think that's
so yeah the two different types of writers and i
find that for the most part those who want to play
god are the outliners and those who you know let
the story live itself don't outline as much and
have a tendency of either going off on tangents
or just getting lost and not knowing what's coming
next when you talked about how you almost thought
it was a detriment to organize your email i'm
wondering if that's actually a strength because
you like that organization and so that that sort
of lends itself to this outline it's possible um
you know because i do i don't do like the like
the the blake schneider like beat outline like i
do full scenes like i i basically
write out full paragraphs of everything
um everything except dialogue i almost have like
a really cool dialogue that possibly then already
down for the most part i my outlines are you know
they're not super long uh i'd say maybe between
10 and 20 pages do you number sorry i don't but i
do like i do a scene heading like i know like the
locations i want these things i still have slugs
uh for each of my things even in my outline um so
like you know like this scene takes place internal
office and an external house blah blah but i don't
sit there and number the scenes um i don't really
find that super important um because one scene
could be multiple scenes once you're in script
form you know like if something's in inside a
house you could have a scene in the living room
and in the kitchen and the dining room and it's
one big one sequence but then it's like broken
down into like three or four scenes you know so
i feel like numbering it isn't really going to
help me much i'm still just going scene by scene
or sequence by sequence as it may be anyway um so
yeah i don't number i don't want to see a point
what's the most you've ever rewritten and
outline revised it i have a script james hook
it's an origin story of captain hook from
peter pan um the outline went through about
four rewrites um then the script itself
went through a ton of rewrites too because
even when i finished it when i had the outline
as solid as i thought i could get it it was like
an 18-page outline the first draft of the script
was 176 pages way too long so a lot of stuff like
got changed you know because it was way too long
and while trying to fix how to get rid of things
i started seeing like oh well these two scenes
could be combined they weren't over here because
it seemed important they were individual
scenes but now i need it shorter and so
it's easier to just combine these a few story
elements even you know changed along the way
based on reader notes whereas like in my head
it was like oh this is fabulous because you're
spending so much time with the story you might
not always see everything that that is wrong
with it so once i send stuff out certain readers
are like oh this comes across as kind of racist
or this comes as sexist or this doesn't work at
all because of this thing that happened back here
that like you might not see it as as clearly
so that's why i always get notes i always do
like i do all the outlining myself i
don't really show my outlines anybody
um and then i do my first draft and then i do my
own rewrite on it before i send out anybody so
nobody sees my story until it's at least a second
draft of the script um and then luckily i get very
good notes to find things that didn't occur to me
even while reading and rereading my own stuff um
i feel like we have a tendency of getting lost
in our own work and falling too much in love
with things and then not seeing that something
doesn't work because you love it it's such a
cool scene but sometimes those really cool
scenes are the things that aren't working
in any capacity other than being cool um and
so if you can tweak things to make them better
you should has anyone ever tried to talk
you out of doing an outline like you know
travis you're spending too much absolutely
um because again i'm a serial outliner i have
i have outlined occur as of right now this today
i have outlines for 14 features and nine pilots
that i haven't written yet so um people are
like why am i spending a lot of time and
i've tried writing without an outline before i
have two scripts that i actually did write without
outlining first and it was hell to
write them because i didn't know
what was coming next and that infuriated
me so much that i'm like i don't know how
to get these characters out of this because i'm
just trying to write off the cuff you know and
um one of those scripts hasn't like nothing's
happened with it and because i'm like it's
it's cool and i like it but i don't i it's it's
also very short um you know like your features
should be you know like the 90 to 120 page in that
range you know 90 to 120 and i think this script
is like 82 pages and it's because you know i'm
writing it out and like it nothing nothing there
wasn't a lot of material there of like just coming
up with the full story in script form whereas if i
if i were to have like outlined it first i would
have seen ahead of time oh my outline's kind of
short like what else is there that needs to be
beefy you know into the story so um and then the
other script that i wrote without an outline was a
page quarterfinalist and has been optioned by two
different producers over the years you know so um
i don't necessarily know that it's the process not
working in a script or for the script not working
but for me writing both of those script no matter
how good one of them may have been to to get
option and place in contest it was hell to write
because i never knew what was happening and had to
constantly be fixing things on the fly where it's
much harder to fix a problem in a 90-page script
than it is in like a 5-10 page outline you know
if you're outlining something it's only 10 pages
and scenes need to be rearranged you can just move
scenes around and see how it works and re-read
the whole thing again in like what 15-20 minutes
of reading to see if it works whereas if you
move something around in a feature you could end
up leaving things behind and of course then it's
going to affect things in the future i would much
rather rewrite you know if i move something at
near the end like let's say it was on page eight
of my ten page outline i moved to page seven i'd
rather rewrite three pages you know as i need to
rather than in a script having to rewrite 30 pages
of stuff that because it changes everything around
it interesting okay so it sounds like that works
because it seems like a lot of people have an
opposition to the uh outline so it sounds like if
you couldn't do it it would really hinder it it
hurts like i i feel like i know writing is a lot
of people say writing is supposed to be hard um
i don't necessarily believe that i don't find
that writing is hard if as long as you find
the time to actually write i think it's more an
issue of writing well is hard um coming up with
the story that works and again i would much
rather try to work that story out in 10 pages
rather than trying to like fix something
that was 90 pages you know uh i've seen i saw
on twitter a writer recently uh he's a
professional writer works on a good tv show who
they were just trash talking the outlining process
completely and i'm like well that's fine for you
if you don't need outline then by all means i
have another friend who refuses to outline and
her scripts are fantastic but if you need to
outline and i do definitely outline and don't
listen to the people who are trash talking
outlining do the process that works for you
i think you finished a first feature script
was it 2005. yeah 2005. that was the one i had
mentioned earlier that was like a personal thing
that had gone through and i was kind of writing
as a therapy sort of thing i didn't know any of
the rules of screenwriting anything like that
um i was just kind of working out my own
issues with it you know with what was going on
in my life so sorry this was at the alarm
company no i don't know 2005 no 2005 um
i was still in michigan in 2005. oh okay um
massage therapy no that was before then even
because i didn't go to massage school to 2010. so
it doesn't i gotta think where i was let's see i
i would have been at that time working in a movie
theater as a concessions clerk oh nice um as one
of my jobs i think i had four jobs simultaneously
at that time okay so yeah i won't go into the
details of what the personal issue was sure that's
fine um although which is weird i still have
people who have read a bunch of my scripts
who still think that's my best script to date
and i'm like that's impossible because i've
written like so many scripts since then but
that is interesting yeah maybe it's because it's
my most personal thing you know because i was
it was literally i was taking the
stuff that was happening to me and
made the exact same things happen to the character
and then just kind of the things i wish i would
have done differently in the situation made
the character do to get out of it kind of thing
um and so you were at the you had four jobs one
of which was a concession stand at a movie theater
you're writing this script in the morning still
um that was kind of like whenever i could sort of
thing because i i like i said my very first script
i didn't know anything about screenwriting i
think i wrote that in ms word uh at the time
so yeah i didn't know anything i was just um
it was literally just my way of venting the stuff
the stuff that was happening you know to me so
um it wasn't until after that that i like said my
second and third script when i started doing other
things like i wanted to do like a superman thing
whatever and when you look at that script where
and where you were at during that time what kind
of writing misconceptions do you think you had
versus now maybe things just feel more clear
to you right i didn't i had never even seen a
screenplay yet by that point um so i i think
i kind of wrote like the dialogue like i had
seen in plays because i used to do like plays
musicals in high school you know um so i was
kind of like going by that so like i had instead
of having character dialogue character die i had
character dialogue character you know so and then
oh he um didn't really know what a slug line was
so everything was just written like a novel almost
but then had like so like yeah it was basically
written like a novel with uh interesting stage
play dialogue character setup um i rewrote it
once i learned about screenwriting i had read
scripts because i started working as a production
assistant in 2007 2008 somewhere on there um then
as a production assistant uh working in the myself
was one of one of my jobs was collating scripts
you know and sending out people so i'm started
reading so i'm like oh that's how it's supposed
to look gotcha all right so then went back to
like that script and all the scripts i'd written
and then like change the formatting up and stuff
how many screenplays have you sold sold i haven't
sold any i've sold a couple shorts which is
bizarre to me that there's a market for shorts
but apparently there there is there's even um
i've heard of some actually big sales of shorts in
fact one of the people who has one of my features
optioned right now they got their start working
for a producer who was making short films for like
sony and they were giving him like 100 000 budgets
on each of these short films yeah i'm like i don't
i don't know what they did with with a hundred
thousand dollar short film at that point but
um there's apparently a market for him so
i've sold two shorts i've been hired to write
a bunch of shorts i've optioned i currently
have three features that are out on option
but total i've optioned seven features that i've
had option but then they didn't turn into sales
um i know one of them was because like they
couldn't get the director that they wanted
and they basically had their mind as that
director or nobody sort of thing so they one had
optioned a thriller script of mine and then when
they were looking for investments they found an
investor to to give them like a very large sum
of money but only if it was for a slate of family
friendly features and mine did not fit the bill
so it went it unfortunately went away um but yeah
i've got of the three that are currently optioned
two of them are supposed to turn into sales within
the next couple of months so i'm hoping that
that works out um but yeah so far i don't have
any like full-on feature sales uh as of as of
today so can you explain the optioning process
sure so an option is kind of like a uh a rent to
own sort of scenario you see like those you know
if you go on craigslist looking for an apartment
or something they'll have like lease to own sort
of things on like condos and stuff so it's
sort of that situation where they will pay you
an obscenely small amount of money uh sometimes
as little as a dollar to have the rights
to the script for between six months and a year
usually um so that way you can't be shopping
around to other people so they know they're
the only person who has the ability to make
that movie and they're going around uh trying
to find either talent or investments or both
um so then they can raise the money to make
the movie if they succeed then they will buy
the script from you so then they can make
it if they don't succeed their options are
either a renew the option for a slightly less
low amount of money um so if it was a dollar
the first time around it might be like okay
now we gotta pay you like 500 bucks you know
um in order to get like an additional year um or
they can just be like okay we couldn't get it done
it's yours again do it what you want with it
so i've had scripts that after that first year
they couldn't do anything with it so it's mine
again um one of the three that i've optioned right
now they've renewed the option like three times so
i don't i don't know what i know they've had like
different successes and failures with it along the
way so i'm hoping that they get more successes but
until then i'm getting money every year just
for them to keep being able to shop it around
sort of thing so um yeah that's that's what
an option is they pay you a little amount to
have the rights to shop it around and then
which is slightly different shopping agreement
um because in a shopping agreement unless it's
an exclusive shopping agreement like you could
still potentially sell to other people um a
shopping even an exclusive shopping agreement
they are getting the rights to like bring it
around but they can only bring it to like select
people they can't just like blanket the town with
it with under a shopping agreement you know they
have to go to specific either investors or or
networks or depending on if it's tv or feature
um like i currently have i have one of my scripts
out on a shopping agreement and i have a shopping
agreement that i own on a book that i wanted to
adapt all right um so for the shopping agreement
there was like no money and i can only shop
it around to specific people like i can't
i can't even tell people what the script is unless
it's a producer who can get it made like you know
so nobody everyone knows oh i wrote an adaption
but they're like why why can't you tell me what
it is because my shopping agreement is that i can
only shop it to people who can buy it so nobody
else can even know it exists um other than knowing
that i wrote it you know and they can't know what
what the script is then go find the book or
anything like that so um and it's a similar thing
on the script that i have out with a producer it's
on a shopping agreement is that they can only talk
about it to investors or other producers like they
can't even talk like try to um get like a star or
anything like that until it's either an option
agreement or sale so yeah and where does one
submit for these optioning opportunities
um so there's lots of ways to do that um
there's a bunch of websites that
have producers that are looking
for specific stuff that you can pitch
things to uh like there's inktip isa
screenwriting staffing mandy used to but i think
they kind of backed off on doing um script stuff
i think it's mostly actors now for mandy um but
they're like you know you pay a certain amount
of money um either like every month or every
quarter uh to basically get a newsletter from them
of producers that are looking for specific things
then you pitch your stuff to them and then if they
dig it then they'll option it or buy it and if
not then they say thanks for no thanks um you can
pitch stuff in query letters uh we'll query emails
mostly now um you get like an imdb pro account
you can gain access to uh not all of them but
a large amount of industry people you can get
like their email or phone number at least where
they work you know like if you want to go after
like a rep you know like if you want to go like
to you know like ata or something you know you
can get the in contact information for the company
producers a lot of times the producers will have
like uh contact for their production company and
then they might even have uh their own personal
contact on there um so you send them query letters
and it's the same sort of thing you know if they
like it great if not oh well um meeting people
in person doing networking um you know i've
one of my things that i i optioned was through a
craigslist ad so there's lots of different avenues
to find the producers you know to get your stuff
out there yeah i always say craigslist can be like
the most amazing experience or horrific yeah it's
just it's a lot of people trash [ __ ] craigslist
because there's so many scams on craigslist you
know there's a lot of things out there that that
but as long as you're investing great stuff yeah
yeah i you know i've i have a producer i met on
there who has now hired me to write like seven
short films um only two of them got produced
that i know of um but you know i would it and you
know because it's a short there's not a whole lot
of money but it's like that's stuff i can pump
out in a day basically you know to write like a
little five page thing for him you know and make
a little cash to you know pay for gas that week
um and then like it's also as long as you're
vetting the people you know making sure that
they're not some like schmuck who's like oh
yeah i'm gonna make a movie you know uh imdb
whether you have the pro version or if you're
just imdb someone you can still find out like
what they've done um google of course you can just
google people um look them up on you know like do
like a search form on like variety or deadline
or anything like that you know you can find out
if they have a track record of any kind or if
there's somebody making their very first script
or movie and even if they are making a very smooth
doesn't necessarily mean they're going to scam you
it means they haven't done anything yet you know
and and those can be very good relationships too
you know um you get in with somebody who it's
their very first script that they're going to be
producing they may not have the budget to do like
some big sale and big production movie and stuff
but you get in it's still a produced credit which
is much better than not having a reduced credit
even if it's a terrible movie having that
credit is is more useful to you than like
just holding on to your babies and not you know
selling your stuff or shopping your stuff around
and i always find too if the urgency of
how fast somebody wants you to do something
if it's like it's got to be now or never
that's a red flag yeah sure um i mean i get
things move quickly but if you're getting like
a weird feeling and they're talking in circles
sometimes that's yeah there's definitely people
are doing the fake until you make it sort of
stuff um when i was still living in
michigan i'm not going to name my names
but when i was living in michigan there was a
producer who was had that sort of thing we're
like oh we have to sign this now now now and
it just wasn't a good deal and they were gonna
like get way more out of it than i ever would
have you know and they hadn't done anything and
they were like i don't even know if some of
the things they were saying are true or not
but like they are making like landish claims you
know like the outlandish claims of who they had
deals with you know of like distributor companies
and stuff that they already have like first look
deals with and stuff like that which may have been
true never know but it's one of those things that
like it didn't seem true and when i looked them
up there was nothing to support their claims
that's a big one right it doesn't necessarily
mean it wasn't true because like i was mentioning
before the cameras were rolling you know like
there's a writer that i know who he makes like
300 grand per draft but if you're looking on
binary he only has two produced credits but he's
written on like hundreds of things you know it's
or or carrie fisher you know she you know if you
looked up on anybody you see all her acting stuff
you'd only see any writing stuff but she was like
one of the biggest you know ghost writers in town
you know being paid to like do touch-ups and stuff
and she was getting paid very well to fix these
scripts you know but you would never know it by
looking up on imdb you know so people could make
claims that are totally true and you just can't
find any information on it but if you can't find
information on it probably not right but then
like you said then the urgency and then if it's if
it's like confusing and it shouldn't be confusing
yeah be looking at the deals and have a lawyer
look at the deals too um you can like attorneys
if it's an attorney that if you if you think
you're going to have a long relationship with
the attorney you can probably convince them to do
a percentage deal as opposed to paying them hourly
that's what i have with my attorney who does all
my contracts i've been with him since 2013 now and
he gets you know a percentage of anything i make
from any of these deals which for him could be a
ton of money if i hit something big you know if i
were to sell my james hook script to like warner
brothers and get paid like a million bucks and his
five percent of that million bucks is a crapload
of money whereas if nothing happens he doesn't get
any money so it's kind of like a risk on his part
too but one that he was willing to make because
he saw potential of having deals in the future
and you know i at this point i'm like i i want
i need one of those big deals so i can give him
his five percent can be more money than you know
paying his rent for a month or something you know
so like the man deserves to live wealthy you know
because he does such he busts his butt you know to
to get me good deals and make sure that i don't
sign anything that is not signable so um habit
attorneys are indispensable even if you get
even if you have to pay one hourly you know
if you're gonna make it have a deal that
you're gonna make a few thousand bucks on
or something like that it might be worth it to
pay somebody like a hundred bucks an hour to
look this over make sure that you're not
signing your soul away for pennies you know
right 100 bucks an hour that's how
inexpensive oh um i yeah i i've seen
most so if you get like an entertainment lawyer
there they could be as low as 100 bucks an hour
they could be as high as 500 bucks
an hour it kind of depends you kind
of got shop around just like you would
you know with any rep um or like i said
my guy i know my guy if i didn't have his five
percent his rate's 130 an hour which is still
not bad when you know most of these things or
whatever but the thing is though you you can't
really pressure him into doing everything one hour
you know like you send them like an 11 page uh
contract you know you're not gonna get even if
it's a hundred bucks an hour you're not you're
paying at least 300 bucks i guarantee it you
know so um it's one of those things you just
kind of got to wait you know if it's going to be
like a little dollar option thing maybe not but
um yeah lawyers are indispensable because they're
the ones who are going to find all the stuff that
is a big red flag that you would never know
because all this legalese it talks in circles
i i understand some of it now that i've had
enough contracts over the years um so i know
things to look out for but there's still stuff
that my attorney and their attorney will will be
having red lines back and forth that i have
no idea why this is a bad thing and why why i
shouldn't sign but if my attorney's saying no then
no and it's harder now because you know before
late 2013 or late or early 2014
they changed the laws a little bit
um with what attorneys can even do for you
because it used to be my lawyer was able to
talk directly to the producers you know on these
deals and they could just discuss the contract
between themselves i could just sit back
let them do their job um but then the law
changed like says i can't remember end
of 2013 began 2014. where now he can't
uh he he can be the he can do all the redlining
on the contract but he's not even allowed to
have to take a phone call with the producer that
i'm that i'm working on because it'll count as him
doing an agent's work at that point okay um it's
all like i i have a deal right now that the the
producer isn't really understanding that he's
getting very angry that you know my my attorney
won't talk about it's like it's not he won't talk
to you he can't legally talk to you you know and
you know it's one of those things that he could
he could talk to you and like risk everything by
doing this just like you know if you're talking on
the cell phone while you're driving you're making
a risk that you're going to get arrested for that
you know or pay a bill uh uh you know it's one of
those things you kind of gotta weigh your risk
options and my attorney will not you know cross
that boundary just in case kind of thing travis
i'm wondering if we can talk about the levels of
dimension in a character so if we could talk about
what a three-dimensional character looks like
and then one that's two-dimensional and
finally just a one-dimensional character
so how does one look flat versus a fully fleshed
out maybe three-dimensional character not sure
how to do 2d that's a interesting concept 1d in
3d makes sense to me 2d i created that yeah okay
uh like i guess 2d is 100 piece of paper so
there's that um so one uh so a single-dimensional
character somebody was just kind of there to
facilitate the plot um like they're there to
basically just be a moving piece along the way
um where they're just an anchor for the story
um they're usually somebody who the story is
happening too and they're not really making any
choices they're just kind of being pushed along
by all the stuff that's occurring around them um
three-dimensional character is more like a real
human being who makes choices and some of those
choices are good and some of those choices
are bad um they're somebody who actually at
least makes decisions about the things you know
they're not somebody who is being pushed along by
like if the killer's running after them they're
not just going upstairs because that's where
the story needs to take place you know there's
somebody who might fight back against the the
bad guy you know um or somebody who may go and
cower in a closet somewhere you know it's very
character specific um you know somebody who may
have a different experience you know like uh
have like the exact same story you have the main
character be a hairdresser they're going to make
way different decisions than a character who's an
fbi agent and that would be a three-dimensional
character because they're all the choices of
of what they're doing has to do with their
experiences 1d character would be somebody who
we don't if it was an fbi agent or a beauty
salon person it doesn't matter because they're
just going where the story's going you know so
um yeah that's my best again 2d is a piece of
paper i don't know what to do with that for a
character or maybe they're an fbi agent that has
a cover as a hair salon and then these women can
find all these things and they're like oh and
then they get these tips are there different
tests though that you when you look at the
characters that you're writing and you say you
know what this is too this is too one-dimensional
right here um well i i try to come up with so i
i'm i'm personally more of a plot writer than a
character writer but even in having a plot you
need the characters to make sense i'm not going to
make i still need to find the character to have in
this place like if i want an alien invasion story
i am not going to write a character that could be
anything just because all i care about is the cool
explosions of having an alien invasion happen and
so i have i need to find i need to find characters
that are gonna make cool decisions that are
cinematic based on what's happening to them so if
i want something that's gonna be like high impact
action where like the good guy is fighting back
i might have a soldier as as the lead character
and they're going to make way different decisions
than like just the general public is you know so
they're going to be helping other people get out
of the situation they're going to be fighting back
against the aliens they're going to be plotting
and scheming and coming up with whatever they
can to survive help others survive and defeat the
bad guy whereas if i want something that's just
a terror driven thing where we are like on
the edge of our seats of oh my god when is
this person going to die i might have just
a regular joe schmoe who has no experience
they're just looking out for themself maybe not
helping other people unless they can't help it um
you know who's going to be cowering in their car
and they are probably going to die at any point
where so at that point it's like oh when is
this person going to die versus the soldier
oh when is he going to beat the aliens you
know and because it's the same setup because
it's a different character it's the same it's a
completely different story now um so it's kind of
one of those things of like okay if i i want this
story to be about a specific to go a certain route
i need to find the character that helps that route
along and isn't just some random person you know
based on what the experience are and even then my
story because again i'm outlining right so in the
outline i'm coming up with okay what character
would best facilitate now i have to think
well what decisions is this character going to
make and how does that change the rest of the
plot that i originally had in mind and so going
from my initial like one sentence thing that i
write my idea book maybe a completely different
animal now that i have the character for it um
yes with your script if we go back to 2005 which
you said was loosely based on you or it was really
yours right it was a loosely based thing like
their thing the character was going through the
same stuff that i was going through um sometimes
a little more dramatic than what my own stuff was
uh and a vastly different outcome from what my
personal experience was uh but yeah like that
script was loosely based on the the situation
i was in do you feel that that character was
three-dimensional or do you feel like the writing
i feel like that character was me uh in a sense
and me kind of living out my own fantasy of
how i like what i feel like i should have done
the first two-thirds of that script was
the character was as weak as i was in
this situation um where it was he was letting the
stuff happen to him and not really fighting back
and i felt like the stuff i was writing was
basically like how i wanted to get out of
that situation but i in real life i was just
too like weak to do it like i knew what needed
to be done i just couldn't convince myself to
actually do it so i had the character who had
the same situation as me and he was just as weak
as i was until he finally found the strength to
push forward and do what needed to be done uh
and even then like once i wrote that point that
was when i was able to like end that scenario
in my own life um it was it was a i was in an
abusive relationship is what that was and so you
know it was almost like a reverse lifetime movie
you know there's a lot of lifetime movies where
like you got the the woman who's being beaten by
the man and stuff you know and following her trail
so it was the guy being beaten by his wife at the
time you know and so i you know in real life like
i couldn't get myself to get out of that situation
oh i don't want to cry i'm sorry oh i'm sorry
oh i feel bad now no worries um so like i knew
that i needed to get out of the situation but
i just couldn't get myself to do it you know
because i i was like low self-esteem at the
time so i felt like i couldn't do any better
than than that and uh so in the writing
he you know rose above it i'm sorry oh
okay so he in the story you know like found the
power that i couldn't basically and rose above
it and then had like a much much different ending
obviously than just leaving leaving it because i
know i wanted to be like kind of cinematic too
so there was like some thrillery stuff thrown
into the third act of that um that obviously
never happened in real life but it was the same
situation the same sort of feelings and it was
kind of like so that's why was it like therapy for
me yeah to get out of it okay what is connectivity
in a screenplay and why is that important
i feel like that to me at least the connectivity
seems like it would go with uh like plot holes
sort of thing like filling it because uh a lot
of new writers when they're writing stuff aren't
really looking at it as a whole they're just
doing like scene by scene by scene by scene
racing and not realizing when there are things
that happen here that you never set up over here
so it kind of feels like it's out of left field
you know like the the the big thing is having like
you know twist endings and stuff like that well
twist ending doesn't work if you didn't set it up
in in advance uh it'll just feel completely
out of left field you know so it to me at least
that's my understanding of from the question you
know with that is is being able to connect the
different aspects of the thing to make it make
sense because if you don't have the setup then
the payoff doesn't work you know or if you do a
setup and then there's no payoff well now you just
ruin the perfectly good setup and
people are going to be mad why didn't
this come to fruition you know right okay so
so just like turn of events different things
it can't just happen where there was nothing
to set something off yeah like i said the twist
doesn't work if there's no no setup if otherwise
it's just a twist for the sake of having a twist
and that never works well right do you think that
it's best though that the audience didn't see the
twist coming i mean in terms of the audience likes
to know something sure they told him even even
in a movie where there's like a twist that you
never saw coming there's usually something in it
that if you were to go rewind it and watch it
again like then you'll see oh that was already
set up in advance sort of thing you know i
feel like in a movie if it's going forward
and then the ending like is completely bizarro
and had nothing to do with anything like i feel
like i'm cheated that feels like a huge like
deus ex machina sort of situation to me of like
there's no way this would have happened
why did this suddenly happen you know
but if there's things that set up i just read so
i i read through a lot of the like the blacklist
scripts and i just read one that was on 2019
blacklist where the ending is kind of a twist
ending but it's something that that if you paid
attention got set up a few pages at least prior
so it wasn't like way at the beginning it got set
up but um and like the twist ending in it was that
it's about a mountain climber who she's climbing
up this mountain and it's like haunted mountain
and and at the very end of it i don't know if
there's gonna be a spoiler because i don't as
far as i know it hasn't got picked up anywhere yet
so in five years from now it may be picked up and
i apologize for spoiling it five years in advance
um but she gets at the end like as she's climbing
um when she gets to the very tip top it turns out
that now she's like a part of like a heavenly sort
of situation and then it suddenly jumps to where
find her dead body like in the cave below um and
it's kind of twisty because it's like also okay
she got the claw what she was dead but it sets it
up because there's a couple different times when
she falls while climbing the mountain and like
miraculously got saved especially the very
last one when she falls and one of the ghosts
catch her is like at that point okay she's still
plummeting when he caught her but it makes it look
like or um what's the one with mandy moore in the
sharks uh oh 457 meters yeah let's try that again
right so 47 meters with mandy moore you know
like the and i apologize again for spoiling stuff
but at the end of the thing you find out that like
a lot of the rest of the a lot of the end of the
script like never happened like she gets saved and
we find out that oh she's actually been imagining
this whole thing the whole time about her having
this final encounter with the shark getting out of
the cage getting rescued coming up on the ship
and then do a really cool way you know she had
gotten like injured along the way and when she's
on the ship her blood is like floating in the air
above her and she's like watching it and then it
cuts down to her still being in the shark tank
and but they set that up it because of the whole
thing of of um like hypoxia and and in running out
of oxygen so you know it starts to like mess your
head hallucinating and stuff that was one of the
first things they talked about in the movie you
know it was like the dangers of being at such a
low depth you know of if you can't come if you
don't come back up in time and they even talked
about it again while she was in the tank with her
sister before her sister like got killed and stuff
by the shark that they were discussing it again
so it's like it's something got set up twice
before we saw the ending so some people you know
watching and stuff like what she imagined that
that's a horrible but no it wasn't because they
set it up twice before then so we kind of saw
that it was a possibility of her hallucinating so
that sets up oh if she could hallucinate then yes
that makes sense for hallucinous ending it kind
of infuriates the audience still because oh i
wanted her to survive and she's not gonna but it
sets it up so the twist works did you see strange
but true with margaret quality i don't believe
so it's an adaptation i think it came out last
year and that one was a shocker and then when you
write when you go back there were a few clues yeah
i don't want to give i mean such a great film
um it was like a dark well you know the one that
everyone keeps go always goes to with the twist
ending you know is uh sixth sense like if you paid
attention you could find that you could figure
out you know or if even if you didn't figure out
if you rewind it watch the second time you'll
find all the different clues along the way that
bruce willis is a ghost the whole time you know
um there's it's a lot of like little minor things
the you i didn't catch it the first time i watched
it most people didn't and people were like what
that doesn't make sense i rewatched a second time
like oh here's where it's set up for it here's
where it's set up for it here's here's two scenes
in a row where it sets up for it so you know
it worked because there were setups like you
don't you didn't realize it along the way but then
it's one of those things that like you look back
on it and find out the movie was much better than
you actually realized that while you were watching
it sort of thing yeah you like m.9 oh yeah i
m a lot of people give him [ __ ] for
some of those yeah i don't know why but
um the only movie of his i didn't like was the
happening uh with the one where the trees are
killing everyone okay that was the only
one that i thought was like two out there
um but like i i'm a huge fan of his stuff i
i really want to see the servant on apple tv
plus i haven't gotten a chance to watch it yet
there's i actually want to see most of the shows
in apple tv plus i'm just like itching to to to
watch those um put it on the vision board yeah
basically not another what seven eight bucks a
month or whatever it is i know but no this vision
board idea is getting expensive now all right
you don't have the coffee expense right yeah
that adds up so so your book 365 a year of
screenwriting tips which is beautifully displayed
behind us and then you also have a copy there now
i think you said first off to begin the purpose
of the book is not to try and make you better at a
specific thing right um so a lot of screenwriting
books will focus on one specific thing you know um
there's a book uh what is it shadow something uh
it's a very good book i can't remember what it's
called the plug it for him um but it's it's all
about characters and how to write characters
specifically villainous characters um then
you have you know like blake snyder's you know
save the cat that everyone loves and stuff that
tells you like how to outline a story basically
and like how story beats work and then you have
you know books that are like either like
specifically about television writing stephen l
sears a prolific tv writer he he was the executive
producer on xena warrior princess and he's got a
book that's just about tv writing and it covers
you know like how to come up with ideas and also
some of the business stuff which is why it's a
very good book because it goes over the business
stuff that a lot of other things skip and pass on
and so my book has like it's not about a specific
thing it's kind of like a general overall arc of
writing um the process of writing the business
of writing what you can expect um you know i've
got it broken down into different parts if i can
get to the table of contents so we've got like the
before you start which is you know talking about
um some of the misconceptions about writing in
general uh it talks about you know like you said
before about like the the statistic that there are
nfl football players and there are screen writers
uh then there's like a bit on writing and there's
prep work uh which is you know about outlining and
and treatments and how to come up with ideas uh
there's a section on format so instead of being
a whole book about format you've got one
section here that's what uh 40ish pages on
formatting and each of the each of the things
are only like a page or less each you know so
um it's all very quick reading um there's a thing
specifically on story thinking characters dialogue
thing on rewriting and then after what to do after
the script is done and there's so it covers a
little bit on everything but it's not it's not
made to make you a better writer it's more of
to know about the writing process what to do
before and after how to get your head in game
and come up with ideas and stuff like that it
also has ideas on how to relax um you know i've
got in there one of the tips is about having a
positivity calendar because it is very difficult
to stay positive in this industry when you're
getting rejections coming at you from everywhere
um so my positivity calendar is is you get your
calendar instead of checking the calendar off with
x's like they do in the movies uh i mark off the
days in the calendar by writing every positive
thing that happened to me that day oh that's
great so then later on if i have like a really
bad rejection or like really wanting this meeting
and then it fell through instead of being like
being alone i can look back at the calendar oh
well okay yes today didn't wasn't so great but
look at all this amazing stuff that happened to me
earlier on in the week and stuff you know or and
yeah it's a good way to keep kept track of your
progress like i also put in there like my pa what
page i ended on on my different on my scripts each
day so then i can also keep track of my progress
like that's a positive thing i i got yesterday i
was on page 23 today on page 34. awesome i wrote
you know a bunch of pages today you know and
another tip in there is uh relax go if you're
in los angeles go to salt and straw get yourself
some ice cream because it's fantastic ice cream
i know where's that by the way they have a bunch
of locations um they're originally from oregon
i believe um and then they've they've got uh in
portland they've got like a couple locations and
now here in la they've got i think five locations
in la there's one on third street in downtown
uh the only reason i don't suggest something else
is nowhere to park in in the arts district um
there's one on larchmont there's one on ventura
uh like up in in noho area um there's one in uh
venice um there's one on santa monica boulevard
uh there's one uh in um downtown disney now
oh no just opened uh last year i think and
then they've got a couple locations i think
the one location two locations down in san diego
so like all along the west coast they've got
salt and straw and they're oh san francisco
they just opened a san francisco one too so
basically everywhere along the west coast uh it's
fantastic ice cream and they change their flavors
every month they they have some really good fun
they have some really bizarre ones too like uh
in april last april for the spring i think they
had one that had chocolate covered bugs in it
oh wow it was a grass flavored ice cream with
chocolate covered bugs um for halloween they
had a blood pudding one that the main
base actually was chicken blood and livers
yeah but then they also have you know like
they all they have regular flavors too
okay do they have they have chunky they have
like chocolate stuff you know and they have um
like right now for february they have you know
a chocolatier series where all the flavors are
based on like a local chocolatier company like if
you're in la it's like all la chocolate companies
um you know like like the comparte and um
31 blackbirds and stuff like that where
they make the ice cream based on those san
diego portland they all have like their own
local chocolatiers that they change their
their recipes for so uh one year they had um
i don't know why i'm talking about ice cream now
so screen rating i'm sorry very hungry i'm sorry
i want to actually go into some of the the
tips that you have one of the first ones is um
regarding cliches so i'm curious what is one of
the most cliche pieces of screenwriting devices
actually absolutely true and then vice versa most
cliche piece of screenwriting advice that is false
okay so cliche that is absolutely writing
is rewriting or something sure you know um
let me think about that for a second uh one that's
true and one that's false so a true cliche in my
opinion i would say is that you should write every
day um because if you get in the habit of not
writing then you're going to stay in the habit of
not writing if you get the habit of writing you're
going to keep writing um if you're in this to be
like if you want to take time off everyone needs
time off you're going to burn yourself out if you
if you write like and never have fun you know so
you still gotta you still gotta take time but
if you're not writing every day then you're not
getting in the habit of writing and it's way
too easy to just sit back and go watch shows
instead of writing your own show and then you
don't get stuff done and that's why it takes
people they've been writing the same script for
the last two years you know and they're not even
close to done with it yet you know like oh yeah
i got the first act on really in in two years um
or they've written just one script and then
never anymore and they're just shopping on the
same script for five years and haven't don't have
any additional stuff so button the seat is a must
uh that i think is absolutely true uh one
that i think is absolutely not true is
um that you have to have everything format perfect
there are certain things that you do need to have
it needs to look like a screenplay so if you
turn something that looks like a novel it's
gonna get thrown in the trash um there are certain
components that it needs to have it needs to have
dialogue it needs to have unless it's a silent
film um it also needs to have description and it
should look about the same but nobody's gonna
fault you if like you have one too many lines
in your description uh so like the thing even in
my book i mentioned that you should try to have
four lines or less in your description paragraphs
nobody's gonna fall at you if it's five lines
they're not gonna be like oh this one paragraph
is fine no not can't do it um typos are one that
i would say you absolutely should fix if you can
but there are plenty of professional writers who
have the occasional typo so they're not going to
throw it in the garbage the first type of they see
unless the table is on page one then they're
probably gonna throw it in the garbage immediately
um so yeah i would say that the formatting can't
oh and then like bolding or not bolding your slug
lines is another formatting thing where people
are like oh if you like nobody like you can't
bold your your slug lines yes you can you can't
underline your slug lines yes you can they're not
gonna throw it away as long as the story is good
they're gonna forgive you like minor faux pas or
alterations of the formatting um so they're not
going to be like oh this is not written correctly
they will do it if it looks nothing like a
script though i will say that if it doesn't
even look like a screenplay then they'll throw it
away but even even things like page length is is
there's some give you know if it you know i've
heard that if it's not 90 pages 120 pages if
it's less than 90 or more 120 it'll get thrown
away that's not true if it's 120 to 123 pages i
won't have fun reading it but i'm not going to
throw it in the garbage you know if a producer
if i think it's good enough story you know for a
producer because i do reading on the side too as
one of my side gigs and stuff for like producers
and for contests and stuff you know um yeah okay
again i feel like i talked way too long no no i
like that okay so um those are the two one that's
a cliche that that is true and one that's a cliche
uh that maybe there's some give on tip number one
experts are liars yeah so a lot of screenwriting
books i feel are there to sell screenwriting books
and one of the first things i say in my book
is that i'm not a guru or an expert of any kind
you know i here's what i've done here's what
i haven't done i'm not going to lie to you and
say i know the answers a lot of screenwriting
gurus will tell you like this is the way it
needs to be done that's why i'm writing this
book so that you do it right there are so many
ways in this industry to to be a writer like
i said some people outline some people don't
um some people follow different methodologies of
storytelling you know like some people may follow
blake snyder's beat sheet some people may
follow the the hero's journey they're very
similar things but they're different i even in
the book i talk about like five or six different
methods of storytelling even i'm not saying one is
better than the other and that you need to write
this way i'm saying here are the options for you
you know what are they uh let me just case that's
that's fine if you can pause the tape oh sure
sure yeah find it uh let's see 134 is where
story starts it's probably around there again i
don't know my i don't have everything memorized
i'll see five types of conflict there's
okay so we got aristotle's version uh
we got the blake lake uh snyder's save the cat
beat sheet heroes journey sid field's paradigm
uh the five act structure the four act structure
because usually you've got three act structure and
stuff well these guys are telling you there are
more structures you can do than just three act we
got the mini movie method uh we got max landis's
rule of three uh you know so it's like there's
that's what one two three four five six seven
eight different versions of storytelling that i
talk about here there might even be
more later on if i messed up on how i
numbered my tips in here that's excellent but uh
yeah so which do you prefer when you're writing
i honestly don't use any of them i just write a
story like i said i'm outlining like crazy and
then revising my outline until i get a bulletproof
story so i'm not really going with you know any of
these specific things like we got the blake snyder
you got you know your opening image set up stated
state your theme then the catalyst the debate the
breaking act two i don't really think about any
of that when i'm doing act one i'm just starting
with okay how does this how does the world open so
that we can know who the character we're going to
follow is and what's going to happen in this story
i feel like you the one thing is that by the
end of act 1 we should know what the story is
going to be about but i'm not going to break it
down because i i believe in blake snare's book
he actually gives you even specific page page
numbers of where the thing should happen by i'm
like that's way by the numbers like there's i it
takes away too much creativity i feel if you're
gonna be like that the the exception i would say
is in television writing because you've got to
go to the commercials um if you're on if you're
on like a broadcasting like nbc or something but
versus streaming um that you need to have like
each act end with some kind of cliffhanger
to bring the audience back after the commercial
break um and you need to do we need if you're good
i would say your a story and b story you should
have them in certain spots so that it it flows
throughout the thing but for feature writing
i don't know that any of these are necessarily
needed to be in any specific order or by a certain
page count as long as they're there um because you
know you look at forrest gump it you can if
you look at forrest gump it's act one is like
five minutes tops and then the rest of it's in act
two for the most part you know and then act three
is like that you know whereas whereas some methods
tell you that like act one should be ending on
like between page 25 and 30 well forrest gump
quelled that didn't it you know exactly one is
up until he's an adult and then suddenly he's
going off to war and like now we're already in
act two and we're only like five to ten minutes
into the movie tops you know right but do you
think for a newbie screenwriter because you know
i'm thinking about like a chef and i remember i
saw the professional a professional shop another
job i've had by the way oh you have i was a sous
chef once oh nice okay so you're used to conflict
and being under stress and i've done everything
so so and i asked the chef do you measure and the
the chef scoffed and said no that's for amateurs
or whatever and but you think that after a while
then you don't need to say sure by this page
there's going to be this plot point you know well
okay so i feel like it's a little bit different
though because i will absolutely agree with the
chef thing because if i'm cooking something for
the very first time as a recipe i've never used
before i'm gonna follow the recipe to the thing
but then once i know what it's supposed to
look like and tastes like i can just start
eyeballing it you know my mom has not used her
measuring cup since probably the day i was born
um she just kind of like okay the recipe calls for
a cup that's about a cup there we go boom you know
um you just kind of go by taste that point but um
and i would say doing by taste is is a good phrase
to use for for the script and stuff is that these
are all the guidelines but it you know if you
if you change your mac and cheese recipe a little
bit it's still a damn good mac and cheese just not
the same mac and cheese that this person made and
so it's you know you're do it you know so it's the
same thing with the scripts like these are your
outlines of of how of the general story right so
like the hero's journey you know you've got like
your epic adventure here here's how it would look
but if you tweak some stuff along the way tell
a different story it's not better or worse than
what he's got it's a different story you know um
and it might be better if the ingredients you use
fit the bill you know so um these are good
things to know as the guidelines which is
why i mentioned so many of them so you can see
okay this is what all the experts are saying
take those and work with them how you want maybe
take a little bit from this pile a little bit from
this pile and tell the stories you want to tell
in the best way you can figure out how to tell it
tip number two okay so tip number two there are
only two screenwriting rules yeah the so i've
got my book here i've even got them labeled for
you rule number one is write a script that looks
like a script which i already talked about right
so if it looks like a novel it's not a script it's
going in the garbage so if it looks like a script
you've or at least got past the first gate because
there are a lot of scripts that come in that don't
look like scripts they're getting like i seriously
when i was uh doing reading for a producer i
was sent the script to read that was 312 pages
i'm not reading a 312 page script it's not
happening so it doesn't look like a script
right off the bat so as long as it looks like
a script like i said even the formatting you
can have little tweaks here and there as long
as it still looks like a script and number two
write a script that feels like
a movie preferably a good movie
if you're obviously wearing tv then it would be
right if it feels like a tv episode if you are
writing this big lengthy thing that feels like it
should be a novel you're getting into characters
minds all this other stuff it's not a movie
anymore if you're telling me something that's
just us sitting here having a conversation this
is great for a youtube video i'm not going to
watch a whole movie of me sitting here talking to
you like even documentaries you they're cutting
away to other stuff right like other things are
happening they're just two people talking to
each other so it needs to look like a movie look
like a script and it needs to feel like a movie
bonus points if it's a good movie like that okay
so don't write war and peace oh yeah and submit it
yeah and don't don't try to have an eight-part
series yeah because if it's if it's a short so
i've been asked a question from people on like
facebook and stuff where they've dm'd me and
asking like okay how do you how can i tell if
it's a short or a feature or show okay if you
can tell the entire story in like 20 minutes or
less and be done with it it's a short if you can
tell the thing if it's gonna take at least half an
hour to tell it and you can have it done in like
three hours and then that's it like we never have
to see these characters again like it's a feature
if it's too short flesh it out to feature to to
get there if it's you know like a little bit if
it's three hours try to pull back a little bit to
make it a feature but it's a feature if you can
tell it you know in a couple of hours but if it's
something that could go on and on forever it's
probably a television series um you know if if i
made a flash like if i'm going to comic books if i
have the flash tv series versus the the flash
movie that may or may not ever even happen now
with with uh ezra miller um those are gonna be
two very different flash stories because in one
they're gonna be telling the story between
like an hour and a half two and a half hours
the other one we're already what six seasons
in and it's still going we can have episodic
and keep going you know um they're gonna be two
very different stories to tell sort of thing so
yes that is so that's that's the thing
with the with it being cinematic is
figuring out where does it fall in line is
it a short is it a feature is it a tv show
is it a book is it like a is it
a comic book series is it a poem
you know all these different things have
different uh sort of world and guidelines
to them because of your story but it needs it
needs to go around the story you want to tell
so if the story you want to tell if you could keep
telling it over and over and over with different
things it's probably a tv series if you're going
to tell me this succinct little story that's cool
and has like a couple different a plot people out
the c plot but it's only going to take you two
hours to tell it it's a feature so keeping those
in mind is how to figure out you know where your
story lies among all of the medium that there is
to create in it might be a painting i don't know
exactly you cannot trash talk the field you want
to be a part of yes uh so this is one of the
things so a big reason i wrote this book to begin
with was because of seeing people on the facebook
screenwriting groups asking the same questions
over and over this particular tip was seeing of
huge faux pas that a lot of writers do where
they're like i'm writing this because there's
nothing good in hollywood there are no good movies
anymore well why are if you're announcing that to
the world like why do you want to make movies if
there's nothing good like what is the point of you
going into a field where you think everything out
there is garbage why do you want to be a part of
this and why are you going to tell people that
you think it's all garbage to begin with you know
it's so yeah don't don't trash this is the field
you want to be in don't start trash talking other
people's work don't trust talk other people who
are working in the industry that you may or may
not ever work with because this is a small town
and that gets around so safer for politics oh yeah
what is screenwriter homework and can you give
me an assignment so your homework can give you
an assignment all right so the homework is doing
the work first off uh but let's go with a specific
assignment for you um you want to come up with
an idea for a story um but you don't really know
where to start so one good place to start that
i have in my book is the comp game so for those
who don't know what a comp is a comp is this meets
that you know so like a movie is harry meets sally
meets air bud what is that movie gonna be so
there's your assignment you come up with and
this is a um since my fiance is sitting here i'll
tell this story okay uh so a script i have out uh
that i'm passing on is called run uh it is a
story about a detective who is being forced to
run non-stop uh in order to save her daughter
from a killer um my placed in several contests
at this point i've been semi-finalist uh in in
like three of them and quarterfinalists another
two um and it's a script that like a lot of people
seem to like um where did that story come from
okay so we were playing the comp game one day
driving to a networking event stuck in traffic
so we were playing cop game coming up with i
was coming with bizarre things she was kind
of bizarre things i think at one point i told
her she needed to do i might have actually said
airbud meets something else so she gave me okay
saw meets speed okay so i'm like okay so speed is
you know the dude in the bus that can't slow down
or it's going to blow up saw is this killer guy
who has these people and making them do obstacles
to save their own lives so i mesh them together
i now have a woman who can't stop running or
her daughter will die and she has to along with
running has to do these various like uh feats that
he makes her do and stuff like oh she has to run
to this point in this amount of time and go if
you don't then your daughter's friend who i also
have kidnapped is gonna die so i'm combining
those two things so there's your homework
let's give you a like a couple of uh comps or
whatever to come up with so okay so how about
16 candles meets home alone okay 16 candles
in the home alone so we're gonna take those
two movies and we're gonna merge together 16
candles you got a story about a girl who it's
her birthday and everyone seems to have forgotten
that it's her birthday uh home alone is a guy who
his parents go on vacation and leave him there
awesome all right so we've got kids home alone
it's his birthday all right so we've got kid's
birthday uh he wakes up nobody remembers his
birthday he goes off he comes home to a house that
is full of stuff for a surprise party but everyone
else is gone they set up and they left him alone
so while he's at the surprise party waiting around
his own party uh some people try to break into his
house luckily he's got things already around now
that he can use to defend himself he has a banner
that he turns into a giant slingshot to shoot the
bad guys across the street uh they come in oh look
here's birthday cake with with uh trick candles
on it so he lights the trick candles now he's got
roman candle torch that he can use as defense and
shoot it off like a big firework of people uh and
then the parents once he's defeated the bad guys
they come home everybody comes home forgetting
that they set up for this birthday party
don't know why there's all this mess here until
the mom finds the uh the banner at the end and
then oh by the way your birthday present happens
to be something he destroyed while trying to do it
idea outside my head it probably sucks i know it
sucks but there that's kind of what the comp game
is you come up with things they may not be good
they may be amazing it's kind of a thing of trying
to figure out how to meld the two things together
because there is i'm a firm believer that there
are no more original stories left to tell because
we've been telling stories since the dawn of time
the trick is to find new ways into the stories and
the reason i have the comp game is a fantastic way
of doing that is taking two stories that already
exist and finding where they meet in the middle
what is it the venn diagram where they've got
the circles and things over here so finding those
things is a great way to to create your own story
by melding other stories already existing i'm just
going to be don't be super obvious about it like i
just was with this 16 candles home alone um like i
said with the run i i knew it had to be something
that couldn't stop moving from speed and there
had to be a serial killer with obstacles like
saw and so i created a whole new character that
went into there uh and how to mesh them together
like she's no longer on a bus now she's running
you know so fine the the original idea in them um
another thing you can do is coming up finding a
movie you like but that has [ __ ] ending can
i say [ __ ] i'm sorry i have a crappy ending
um and uh tweak it to okay how would you have
ended this story can you now write a story that
ends that way and has a different beginning you
know so so you can always borrow from other things
like um even and people borrowing even even uh
william shakespeare was borrowing people you know
romeo and juliet was not an original thing
he stole romeo and juliet from like a greek
mythology thing and then just made his own tweaks
to it you know so we can make our own tweaks to
everything so your homework is to find a story
that already exists find a way to spin it and
make it a completely new original story okay argo
and sleeping with the enemy oh crap can we just
cut i don't want to do that anymore oh jeez we
could end it there okay sorry i just wanted to
throw out that one okay now i'm thinking about
it though i'm thinking about that that was
just for fun no we won't do that so somebody got
kidnapped and it was it turns out that it was his
lover but in order in order to save his lover
he has to make a movie that involves his lover
this actually sounds like a good one okay
this is a fun game so it should be a party
game yeah you should i can see michael's crafts
there's a similar party game
pitchstorm is similar that one it doesn't do it
doesn't do quite the same thing it doesn't take
movies and make you combine them a pitch storm
is it's a card game where in each on the cards
they have different elements like a certain type
of character and a certain scenario and you have
to come up with the story that uses that and
you're pitching it and then um it has kind of
like a an apples-to-apples component so there's
a judge and the judge is actually throwing out
things too they're actually being the executive
you know and so while you're telling the story
at any point they can still be like oh but what
if and then they have an executive card that has
like some random thing that they throw in there
some note that they're like oh what if you know
you're so i'm telling my story of ron you know the
the woman who's let's say my thing was a detective
and and running and so like i'm telling the story
okay so she's running and the detect or the bad
guy calls her and tells her she has to get to this
certain point and he goes oh let me stop you what
if suddenly aliens drop down so you know it's
a bizarre little game like that it's a similar
concept but not quite the same i i've thought
about trying to to do that but i'm not sure
i'm not sure what the legality would be of as
far as the copywriting stuff you know putting
out a game where i'm where it's like a bunch
of movie things that you haven't come out you
can do it on your own so you know it's not really
something like phil needs to have it but i'm like
it could be like a extra thing to go with
the book i guess yeah that's true of your 365
tips which is one or two that you have the most
trouble following yourself that's tricky that's
tricky tricky tricky let's find out well
okay self-fulfilling prophecy tip number ten
that one my sister again my sister's psychologist
gets on me all the time and stuff um can i
actually just read it or no sure please do all
right it actually starts with my little sister
psychologist see if she's the one who inspired
the tip number ten self-fulfilling prophecy my
little sister is a psychologist she loves to
warn me against self-fulfilling prophecies
what's that basically if you think something will
happen it might happen but if you think something
won't happen it definitely won't happen keeping
a positive attitude keeps you in a better mood
and ensures you're working towards staying that
way but if you think negatively believe you're
going to fail you will fail because you'll get it
in your head that you're going to fail and you'll
subconsciously keep yourself in the failing
mindset making it nearly impossible to succeed
don't get yourself into a negative self-fulfilling
prophecy don't tweet it don't say it don't
even think it stay positive that is one i
definitely have trouble with because i'm
wanting to get meetings for these awesome new
shows coming out but nobody's returning phone
calls or and so i'm like oh this is never
gonna especially when you're getting on
twitter and and facebook and you're friends
with people who already are professional writers
you're hearing about all the cool shows
they're getting meetings for or you're
hearing about them having like a sale meeting
next week with abc to sell their show to them
or they just got this really cool assignment
through crypt tv to write a horror series for
them that's all so daunting when you're trying to
do it and not doing it so vaughn i start saying oh
i'm never gonna get there because i haven't
gotten there yet now i'm keeping myself in that
mindset i'm never gonna get there and and keep
failing and failing failing whereas if i keep
that's fantastic for them i'm going to get there
really soon you might actually get there really
soon now because now you're striving towards
it whereas as soon as i get the depression of
i'm never going to get there well right because
now i'm going to stop doing working as hard
because what's the point anymore right so that's
definitely a pitfall that i have a problem with
and she will tell you that that's absolutely
true we just had this conversation last night
so that's one issue and that's a really good one
yeah that was the first one that came to mind
about that um let's see turn off facebook
is tip 54. procrastination much yes i do
um
let's see those are probably the two big ones i
have a problem with okay those are good oh female
descriptions i definitely accidentally at least on
my first drafts we'll definitely be using things
talking about like how attractive someone is and
it's not like stuff that flies anymore especially
when you're doing it only with female characters
and not with guys like why is all your female
characters attractive females but all your men
are just who they are you know it seems a lot um
i'll even and this one's the short ones i'll even
read this one for you beautiful gorgeous stunning
sexy a knockout the kind of girl that is so hot
that would be so hot if she didn't have makeup
do you see where i'm going with this using these
sorts of statements to describe your character is
boring and flat and a bit sexist even if it's
not meant to be but there's no normal girls in
your script they're just all gorgeous pieces of
ass huh but then the problem is that a lot of
writers will have those descriptors for the women
you know they'll have like debbie 34 hot blonde or
you know jessica age 26 is an attract would
be very attractive without her glasses or
something but then the men are dan 54 the kind
of guy you don't want to get in a fight with
how does that tell you what is about you know
you're using looks of the girls but for guys
you're using personality traits why you know so
i i feel like i fall in that especially in my
first in my early drafts like when i'm doing like
a first draft of the script because i'm in my head
like the first thing comes to my mind is is what
type of person like what they look like so i can
figure out who would play them because i like to
kind of sometimes cast in my head so i can kind
of think of mannerisms and and that sort of thing
um so the first thing that comes to my mind is is
what they look like i feel like a lot of writers
probably have that same issue but the problem is
we're only doing it for the women i'm not i'm
not telling you how ruggedly handsome bill
is you know so what if it was a writer
that was attracted to bill whether they
were male or female and they this is what was
visually appealing to them and so if they were
at a coffee shop and they saw bill walk by
they would be like wow he is ruggedly handsome
oh my goodness and whoever whoever the writer's
perspective is sure they're just writing who they
find each other i think it comes to not knowing
your character well enough yet because you're
just going on that initial instinct
you know if i see somebody at a party
i can see okay they're attractive or they look
like a freak or whatever i don't know who they are
yet so i can't tell you oh this is like somebody
that you know they're very soft-spoken until you
get on something that they're passionate about
because i don't know that yet i'm just looking
at them so that might be an issue of like you're
writing the script and you're not quite sure who
the person is quite yet especially not outlining
my but i outlined so my problem is just that it's
i'm going with the visual first and and worrying
about character in like later drafts because i'm
you know still telling i'm i know what they're
gonna do i just don't know who they are yet
sort of thing you know so um so then for someone
who's writing a character that they are attracted
attracted to sure whatever the the
gender um not focusing so much on looks
right because especially if you're not
doing it across the board if you're telling
every person what every person looks like that is
one thing it's also going to be a little boring
by telling what every single person looks like
i hate reading the scripts what they're wearing
there are so many i've read so many scripts where
they tell me the costume that they're wearing in
every single scene i don't need to know we're
blue jeans here but they were khakis over here
it's not important it's not story right that's set
dressing and you know and but so like if you're
if you're going to go and tell whatever you see
even even using ethnicities i feel like it falls
in the same category you know if you're going
to tell the ethnicity of every single character
great but if you're assuming white and you're just
pointing out this person's black like that feels
racist kind that's true you know um like so either
across the board tell whoever tell what everyone
looks like or across the board don't tell us
what everyone looks like and tell us who they are
got it okay that makes sense i like that i'm
not sure which tip it is but let people read
your stuff versus don't show your unfinished
manuscript to anyone so i think the the trick
there is the unfinished aspect everybody
and this is another tip that's in the book
that you probably hear frequently is that the
first draft of everything sucks i don't care how
good you are your first draft is terrible compared
to what you can make it so if it's unfinished it's
already [ __ ] don't show it to people because
they're gonna judge you based on what they've read
so if the thing is not done yet don't don't
give it to people to put in their eyes because
if it's not up to par that's all they're
gonna see is that you're a subpar writer um
on the other side though of needing
to show your stuff once it's ready
get it out to the world i've met many writers
who are very precious about their material
and they won't enter screenplay contests because
they're afraid that people are going to steal it
which almost never actually happens there are
obviously a couple cases like the whole thing
with the matrix way back when stuff that oh it
was stolen from i don't know if it's true or not
but there are there have probably been like a
couple of thieveries along the way but it's very
infrequent because it would cost the production
companies way less money to just buy your script
than it would to pay off a lawsuit
against them for stealing stuff
um but if you don't show your stuff out there
either whether it be out of fear of them stealing
it or out of fear that it's not good enough
you'll never know if it could get sold anywhere
if you if you're like oh well i don't know if
it's good enough i don't want to show anyone
because i'm i'm nervous about the quality of it it
might not be good well then you're never going to
know if it's good enough because nobody has been
able to read it to tell you if it's good enough
um so it absolutely needs to get out there but
not before it's ready okay that's good have a
laugh every 10 pages a scare every 10 pages and
action every time sure so this goes with the
genres so that the trick of you know if it's a
comedy if it's supposed to be a comedy and i'm
reading it i'm 50 pages in and i have not even
smiled probably not funny um so the trick is to
whatever your genre is for the script have
an element of that genre like every 10 pages
um that way it keeps it fresh in your head oh
this is supposed to be scary because this scary
thing just happened here and now it's happening
again um or comedy oh i just laughed you know a
couple pages ago here's another joke okay this
is clearly a comedy because if you stretch out
using comedy as the best example if you go too
long and it's not funny that's a drama it's not a
comedy anymore um or if if you're writing a drama
and i don't care about anything that's happening
it's just boring but if it's a horror and nothing
scary happens how is that how is that a horror at
that point you know it might be a thriller you
know where because there's there's a fine line
going between thriller and horror uh but if it's
if there's not scary stuff happening it's not
a [ __ ] because it's not scary so yeah so the
every 10 pages basically just keeping that genre
continuing throughout the whole script what's your
favorite tip of the 365 my favorite of the 65 uh
i would say let's see if i can find it here um
okay so i'm gonna say it's my favorite
because i think it's the one that gives
the most information it's actually several
tips in a row i'm just having problem
figuring out where it is is actually
about writing will not make you rich
a lot of people seem to think that oh
i'm gonna sell my script quit my day job
i'm gonna be a screenwriter forever it's gonna be
awesome that's not the case though if i can find
i think it's like three or four tips in a row
i can tell you exactly why um but basically the
money that you think you're going to make is not
all yours for starters because a you got to think
about taxes you know depending on where you live
you're going to have federal taxes taken out of it
state taxes taken out of it uh self-employment
tax taken out of it and city attacks taken out
of it depending on where you live you're also
gonna have all the percentages from your reps
taken out of it so suddenly you've got like
your 100 000 payday and you're getting like
40 000 left of it that's yours and now it
doesn't look like such a fantastic payday anymore
common misconceptions about what a writer
should do after their script is finished
let's see one is getting your script registered
with the wga versus having it copyrighted
versus mailing it to yourself i've seen many
writers who still believe that if you mail your
script to yourself that counts as a copyright
no it does not it will not hold up in court
the only thing that will hold up in court is
a copyright where it has an official document
attached to it that says this script was doc was
copyrighted on this date uh wga registration is
still better than mailing it to yourself but it's
not quite as good as a copyright um especially
with the way they change uh like their copyright
or their registration and stuff only goes like
overall it doesn't go like per draft whereas the
copywriting you're going to want to copyright
each thing that way you get proof of it it's a
little more expensive to copyright but it's the
safest thing if one of those very rare stealings
ever happen what's a paranoid screenwriter the
people who are afraid their stuff is going to
get taken people who won't send their stuff out
to competitions won't send their stuff out to
producers without an nda never ever send an nda
to a producer be like oh you can't read my script
until you know they'll just give you your nda back
you're like well then i don't need to read your
script um which i've met several people who think
that they need to send an nda out in order to get
a producer no the producer is not going to send an
id you need to send an nda for the producer
possibly if you if you want to work on the
project that they're needing to hire a writer for
you know to save their butts that you're not then
going to take their idea and go write it yourself
without them but they will not sign an nda for you
how about put it in a drawer for a month oh yeah
um i because you fall in love with your writing
you you spend so much time coming up
with the story you think it's fantastic
it's gonna be very hard to find things wrong
with it if you still think it's fantastic
so i put the script away work on something else
in the meantime then come back to it because then
i'm not in love with anymore in fact i probably
have forgotten what some of the stuff even was
and then when you're reading it you can see
all the stuff that now sucks and you're like oh
this needs to be fixed like why didn't i and
you're going to feel dumb for not knowing and
i'm like why did i even write this it doesn't make
sense with this part but if you if you because you
need to do the rewriting like like i said first
draft sucks period end of story across the board
no matter what you write it the very first thing
you write is awful um and it's gonna need to be
rewritten in order for other people to see it
because again you want like we said you want
to send your stuff out there to to get eyes on it
um but you want to do that once it's in the place
where it's i don't want to say this where it's
where it's good enough right so you need to do the
rewrites and if you do rewrites immediately you're
probably not going to be changing much because you
all it's all still fresh in your head about
what you're writing and why you're writing it
and the mood you were in when you were writing it
how much you loved it and oh this song that was
playing was so good and so inspiring and well
now you're reading it a month later you don't
have that song playing you don't really remember
what why you wrote certain lines of dialogue and
now you're like wait this this character made
a choice it doesn't really make much sense and
why would this person talk like this that
doesn't that doesn't sound like her why
so then you get to see all the flaws coming
out that you wouldn't have known uh have they
been around like absence makes the heart grow
fonder with people with scripts absence makes
you realize what isn't so great anymore what's
a serial starter and how do i know if i'm one
serial starter is somebody who starts writing
a script then gets an idea for another script
starts writing that script i think it's an idea
for another script starts reading that script
so they have all these projects that they've
started writing but they haven't finished any so
i keep what i call an idea book it's this little
moleskine notebook about like palm size any movie
idea tv idea anything like that i jot down the
note in there i do not bother writing anything
until i have finished what i'm currently writing
on because otherwise i'll never finish um
so yeah serial starter is one who starts
project after project of the project without
ever actually finishing any of them with the
mindset oh i'll come back to it but you never
will because you're always going to have new
ideas that are new and exciting and fresh
and you want to start writing it while it's
fresh in your head and then you just kind of
everything else kind of keeps getting pushed
further and further back as these new ideas erupt
what is a uh a worrywart screenwriter somebody
who's constantly fearful of the writing process
um someone who's constantly thinking that
they're not good enough so they don't want
to send anything out um somebody who is
afraid of of getting their material out
there even afraid of writing the material think
they have writer's block which doesn't exist
by the way writer's block is typically a
combination of either fear or perfectionism
or laziness those three things combined make
writers block so we're someone who's afraid
of getting writer's block but it doesn't exist
so don't be afraid just write your butt off um
yeah somebody who just they're not progressing
because they may be fearful of success or fearful
of failure both of which are very real things
which i i would have never thought why would
anyone be afraid of success right well the problem
is if you succeed now there's all this pressure on
you to keep succeeding so now you're it's almost
like oh god now i'm gonna fail or if you succeed
oh now i have to be a success i don't know
what a successful person looks like how do i
maintain this i'm a fraud you know and then you
start start getting into the whole uh like the i'm
not good enough sort of scenario and all because
you succeeded and you how do you how do you
follow up that success you know fear of failure
super obvious you're afraid you're going to fall
flat on your face well if you never try you can't
fall on your face sure but you also can't succeed
at that point what kind of work do you do before
working on a screenplay what's the pre-work
coming up with ideas which we talked about
a few different ways to try and do that
um outlining is again like for me outlining is
the most important process again it might not
be for other people is for me i have
to outline and hammer that story out
before i even start page one of any script whether
it be tv or feature or short or whatever um
so that's yeah that's my pre-processes first
coming when i when i first and i come up with
ideas different ways some of them are from dreams
i've had some of them are from watching other
movies or reading other scripts or doing the comp
game of combining things like that um i actually
was reading like i've been reading some of the
blacklist scripts and i've actually come up with
two ideas in the last couple days that sprung out
of my head from other scripts that i was reading
that have nothing to do with the scripts i was
reading but something that they said in the script
tweaked an idea i was like oh that would be a
really cool what if i use like this line that
they use but then that strikes this whole new
concept you know um so one of them like uh the
the mountain climbing movie i was talking about
haunted mountain so they you know they're they
um she's along with climbing out and her her team
with her is basically making a documentary about
her um you know so you've got like a bit of a
found footage like going back and forth being
like some found footage in real life stuff um so i
was like okay well what if we had took that found
footage aspect of it and we had somebody you know
also the point of the movie of the the mountain
climbing thing is it's a mountain that no one's
ever climbed i'm like okay well we have somebody
going going or doing something that no one's ever
done before and getting it all on camera and then
i'm like oh what if we made it a long distance
space travel movie and we take an elon musk type
character who's invented this brand new uh method
of space travel and he's gonna be the one to test
it out he's getting everything on footage and
boom had nothing to do with that script other than
there's cameras involved and going somewhere
no one's ever gone before so that came out of
that idea and then i read another script
about um it was it was a pilot i think
um no it was a movie it was a movie and i'm
coming up with a pilot uh the idea i had
was a pilot where the uh the guy they were
they had this um technology where they were
able to go into it was a uh i can't remember
the name of the movie they're the script there's
no blacklist script it was a soldier who she had
ptsd and they were trying to like fix her ptsd by
having instead of having regular therapy
sessions like this they came up with this
vr scenario situation where they they had taken um
all of the uh audio footage of like the specific
um mission that she was on that kind of triggered
the ptsd and she was having to relive it but she
was realizing there were things wrong with the
thing like they had some other their facts wrong
like who went into the building first they had
wrong and they had like um the color of a building
right like some minor stuff that seemed minor
and but later on the script became major things
so from that i came up with the idea of oh well
what if we have a tv series a detective show where
they have this technology to basically rebuild
the crime scene in a virtual world and go in there
and take different people's like the different
eyewitness testimonies and then the different
like the splatter tests whatever and they can
rebuild the entire thing and then see how the
crime actually happened i'm like that's in my
head that seems like a cool idea show that i
would watch you know i don't know i'm not sure
how many seasons i would watch but but it's at
least a cool little idea came from just like a
piece of technology you know so i come up with
come up with story ideas from pretty much anywhere
uh either so i've seen stuff i've done dreams
i write the ideas down in my idea book where
i have at this point literally hundreds of tv
and movie ideas i think the last time i actually
counted it was 212. um but that's it's just like
a little one sentence thing some cases it's like
just a title of something that popped in my head
and whenever i need something new to write i go
through there try to figure out what seems like
viable ideas right now what actually sounds fun
to write right now because not every idea you have
is going to be something fun um sometimes it's
like big cool action stuff and you want to write
those and sometimes it's like very small personal
dramatic indie type stuff you know that it might
not be in the mood for right now because it's
going to depress the hell out of you while you're
writing it so find something that sounds good i
want to write then i spend time actually coming
up with okay here's the one sentence where's the
story in that doing my outlining process for that
i do all my outlining by hand i find it much
easier for the ideas to flow when i'm sitting
there writing it out again my handwriting is so
bad that sometimes i can't read it afterwards
i do my best um and then i'll go through either
rereading it in there making changes in the
notebook or typing it all up and then realizing
oh this doesn't work and it can change things
from the typed up version of the outline and
hammering it out till it's bulletproof and then
i write the first draft of the script that was
a very long answer for that question i apologize
what do writers get wrong with the first 10
pages of a screenplay not being interesting
i've seen too many people have flashbacks in
the first couple pages but it'll start with a
flat what are you flashbacking from if that's if
that's the first thing you're having happen that
doesn't make any sense um not giving us enough
about the character we're going to be following
like a lot of a lot of horror
especially you know we'll start off with
something that's has to do with like the killer
like how they're killing people but has nothing to
do with the characters we're actually following
you know so it's like a little teaser thing
so it does its job in telling us okay this is
what the movie's gonna be about we still don't
even know who we're gonna be following so i feel
like in the first 10 pages you need to have who
we're gonna be following what the story's gonna
be about be interesting for the love of god um and
give us some some reason to to turn the page to go
on to the next uh pages and the rest of the script
did you like guardians of the galaxy the first
one i loved it the second one not so much
why um i feel like they went too big with the
second movie um and then couldn't wrap it up in
a way that made any sense um they also i felt like
in the first movie did like a really good job of
um taking the humor and the action and the drama
and melding them together in a good way in the
second movie i felt like they went way too much
with the funny because they like that was what
they were banking on from the first movie was that
it was a superhero movie that was kind of a comedy
and now they added too much comedy and went too
big with who the villain was and they could never
get back to the main core of the story and they
kept the main characters apart for too long
before they brought them back together so
it was like their character dynamics they
weren't able to play off of each other because
they were suddenly not the same scenes anymore
and so all the stuff that worked really well in
the first scene the character dynamics the comedy
um you know a medium level of threat for
them they just kind of like went off and
off the handles and and lost track of everything
in that second movie on the flip side what about
sicario the first one not even not okay okay so
we want as i was going to ask what what what do
you think sometimes is the breakdown between the
first one is it because the the first film of of
a trilogy or whatever is is um is a new world it's
fresh the characters are interesting because we
want to get to know them but then we tire of them
or and i'm not saying that happened with sicario
sure again i don't see either of them so i have
no opinion on that movie whatsoever oh that's
a cool title um i would say that going from an
original movie to the sequel the problem okay well
i feel like because you you need to
follow it up with something that's a
little bit bigger because the the whole point
of any movie is rising stakes throughout the
course of it you know you're starting with
someone who's in their regular normal world
and then [ __ ] with their lives and so going
from the first movie to a second movie you want
to keep that going but i feel like the two big
pitfalls of a sequel is either a it goes too far
um where it's like a huge leaps and bounds beyond
what the first movie was and it's how did they get
there from here like that's such a huge jump or
they don't have even as big of stakes where they
kind of like pull it back a little bit too much
um i don't know that we get necessarily tired
with the characters per se like i will watch
every marvel movie that ever comes out for the
rest of my life because it's cool and i love it
but i and i'm not getting tired of the characters
because they are keeping it fresh with the types
of situations that the characters are in same
thing goes with television series you know they're
constantly getting like more and more dramatic or
bigger and badder characters and they're different
types of characters that they're having to face uh
i mentioned the flash earlier like the problem
with like the first three seasons of the flash
the bad guy was always another speedster so he's
just going against somebody who has the exact same
power set as him so then with later seasons
they started giving him characters who had
totally different power sets so i think it was
like two seasons ago maybe possibly three they
had uh the thinker was his bad guy you know where
his hit the bat the thinkers superpower was just
figuring out everything like five ten steps
ahead of the flash knowing everything that's
gonna happen and can set up all the dominoes
so they fall exactly the way he wants it
um and then you know so it's like something that
flash couldn't beat that because he's really
really fat he's a smart guy because you know he he
works uh for the the police department you know in
the forensics department so he's a smart dude but
his thing is think is moving really fast so how
does he compete with somebody who is thinking
everything you could possibly do no matter how
fast you move he knows all the possibilities and
has set up you know based on that so it needs
to keep changing and evolving as opposed to just
being the same story over and over but you need to
make sure to not go too far with the evolution
to the point that it's not realistic anymore
do you have a hard time getting people in higher
positions to read your screenplays oh god yes
it's like it's the big catch-22 that is one of
those like the conceptions that were true uh
absolutely is the catch-22 issue because people
producers don't want to read your work unless
it's coming to them from someone they trust so if
you don't have an agent you're probably not going
to get read by netflix in fact with netflix you
won't even get ready you don't have a show runner
lined up already even um they because there are so
many people writing scripts that first of all most
of the scripts coming in are gonna be from amateur
writers and so they can't read all these thousands
i think there's something like uh or was it 10
000 scripts get registered with wga every year
that's not even counting like going to copyright
you know so that's a lot of material coming in
and most of it is coming from amateurs when you
think there's only like 4 000 people in the wga
um so they're not going to want to sit there
and spend all their time doing that so they're
only going to read vetted material and the ways to
vet someone is having it come in through an agent
although that's different now with the the
strike stuff going on you know with the wga
versus the agencies um or a manager that they
trust or another producer that they know who who
maybe has read it you know and it's like oh this
isn't for us but it might be for you sort of thing
or if they have a personal connection with you
which is where the whole networking thing comes in
um and if it's not coming from one of those vetted
avenues or a screenplay contest if you want a
script contest then they'll probably want to read
it but unless there's a way they can vet it you're
a nobody to them and they don't want to read 10
000 nobody scripts if they have this pile of like
10 that they trust and how did you get your agent
i got i don't have an agent i have a manager oh
i'm sorry and she kind of came to me again it was
through twitter that she found me that's great uh
last year um during staffing season they had the
wga staffing boost tag you know the wga staffing
boost and i had posted something on on there that
um latoya morgan who had started it like retweeted
and that was where all i think all these followers
coming from and then my manager happened to see
the two and was like well what kind of stuff do
you have and so i pitched a couple things she
looked me up on indb and was like okay send
me this and this and she loved my stuff so
she's repping me and um sending my stuff out there
like i said i got her at the very end of staffing
season last last year so it was about time i was
even rep for her to start singing stuff out like
almost every show was already fully staffed so
i couldn't really get any meetings last year
but fingers across for this season i know i'm
they're they're still shooting pilots um so a
lot of things that are fully staffed now are the
stuff that went straight to series already but the
things that just got pilot orders uh they won't
be doing staffing for another like three to two
to five weeks basically you know like beginning
of march they'll start probably um so fingers
are still across i know there's at least three
shows that i'm on a read list for right now that
hoping that goes well but yeah so my manager
kind of just came to me based on a tweet that's
really cool yeah especially after years of
sending stuff out to reps and either them
not connecting with the material or them meeting
with me and we just decided it wasn't a good fit
you know based on what they want to do what i
want i want to do and that sort of thing so um
it definitely felt like a bizarre turn of events
to go from me doing all this work of like querying
everybody and not really getting anywhere with
it to be like here's a tweet about who i am and
what i write and then a manager coming to me
being like that sounds great let me read you
you know so do you think you were just
ready though would you have been ready
two years earlier i feel like i've been ready
for years um maybe not for television as much
uh like i moved out here because i wanted to work
in tv my experience before i moved out here was
like i had written a couple of specs for existing
shows to enter into the into the different
fellowships and then i got hired to write the
eight episodes of that british sci-fi series that
again still hasn't even picked up um but i feel
like i'm more ready now to deal with people than i
would have been when i first moved out here having
not known what to expect because again when i was
in virginia all my communication was either on the
phone or via email and now that i'm here i need
meetings it's all about the meetings so i don't
think i would have been able to handle a meeting
when i first moved out here as was proof like i
said my first meeting two days after i got here
was not good so now that i've met with a bunch
of people and i've done the networking thing
and i've done talking and now i actually know
some people in the industry that i didn't know
when i moved out here um maybe i'm in a slightly
better position for her to actually do something
with with me you know i feel like though people
in whatever pursuit they have out here they
need those like couple bad experiences sure to
kind of like earn their stripes a little bit
you don't really know necessarily how it all
works until you're in there you know you can read
all the book you can read this book available on
amazon um you can read all the books you can read
all the articles that come through you can watch
all of the videos uh but until you're actually
doing it yourself all you have is theory you know
it's kind of doing it's like doing physics without
ever doing physics sort of thing you know i
i can read you a textbook that doesn't mean
you have any idea what it all said until
you sit down and do an experiment you know
um so yeah those bad experiences are what
helps you move along to even understand how
the industry works right and i think it it's good
to get knocked down a couple times because then
it just it's just there's something that kind
of fortifies you a little bit and so when you
actually have a good experience i don't
know if you go as high because you kind of
like it keeps you a little more level-headed i
think i was trying to think of a great quote it
just fell out of my head um but it's one of the
things where you you don't know what you have
until you've lost it sort of thing okay so i feel
like it's almost like a reverse of that you don't
know where you can go until you've already like
seen the bad stuff like you don't know how success
is going to look so you've seen how failure looks
you know that's true i like that it's good you've
mentioned reading list a couple times can you tell
us what reading list sure so like for the shows um
it's mainly a tv thing um you know the show runner
will get a stack of scripts that they need to go
through so they can try and pick who they want
to hire for their their show um so i've gotten
a couple of my scripts on that stack but it just
hasn't you know like i said when last year was
at the very end of the season so it was like they
only had like one spot left to fill by that point
and they still have a stack of scripts there so
but you can't even get on that stack of scripts
without the representative to like either manager
an agent you know pitching your stuff over there
you can do a little bit more with twitter
now because after the whole thing last year
when the wga and the agents clashed a lot of
show runners like latoya morgan and some others
uh liz alper um javier what's javi's last name
i'm drawing a blank and hobby's last name but
like these big show runners that are like okay
well we're not dealing with agents anymore so
writers who should we be looking at and that's
where the wga staffing boost came in of writers
who are reading other people and be like oh this
person has this spec that's amazing you need to
check it out they would be great in your room
before that it was agent or nothing basically
agent or manager or nothing like so you can't
even get on this on the list i got myself on
a couple of read lists using the wga staffing
thing um those shows end up not getting picked
up so i didn't even need to really meet with
the the writers but it was like writers who
had a show that was really cool to me i loved the
pilot when i read it and they're like yeah if this
had picked up i'll i'll take a look at your stuff
you know that would have would have never happened
before the whole mess with the wga and the
agencies last year um so yeah that's what the list
the reading lists are is is the list of scripts
that the uh the shareholders are supposed to go
through and and it's again if they don't have to
go through the whole stack they're not gonna so if
you're coming in there from a rep that they trust
or if another reader they that they know suggested
you you're going to get read before the ones
that are just you know randomly submitted to them
have you always had thick skin when it comes
to writing criticism god no um i'm not even
convinced i have thick skin now because i i'm
i'm very good at taking a note from someone and
trying to figure out like how to fix it or if i
don't understand the note like how to find the
note within the note sort of thing and see like
if what the deeper problem is to fix it overall
but i still there are still some notes that
make me upset where i'm like how could you not
understand this it's right there on the page um
yeah so it doesn't happen as frequently as it did
when i was younger and was newer but and i try
to keep that at bay where if like if something
even irks me just a little bit like thank you
for the note and then i'll come back to it
later and be like okay maybe there was something
there let's take a look at it calm myself down
but nobody's perfect and i sure as
hell i'm not either that's fine okay um
what would you tell someone who wanted to quit
their day job today so that they could pursue
screenwriting full-time don't do that don't
do that again like there's i couldn't find
the chapters in the book uh in a quick but you're
not you're not going to get rich right away and
you're definitely not going to get rich right
away without having some way to pay your rent
and there's no reason to go homeless in the
pursuit of it like there are plenty of people
uh what's her name jk rowling like she was going
again like how many like hundreds of rejections
before her book finally got picked up if she
didn't have her job like she would have been like
homeless like even more because i've read stories
where she couldn't feed her kids or whatever
it's like that would have been even worse if she
had quit her job to write that book you don't quit
your job until you even and even once you've had
a success you know unless it's a tv thing where
now your new job is writing in a writer's room um
because like i said even if you sold your script
for a hundred thousand dollars after you pay all
your stuff you got like forty thousand dollars
and how much are you making in the year right like
compare that to your job like sure if you want to
take a year off but don't if you're quitting it
to start pitching stuff that's insane i'm sorry
you like you need to pay rent you need to eat you
need to feed your kids and family if you have that
uh your dog would appreciate having some
food as well like do not quit your job until
you are making enough of an impact where you can
just survive on the screenwriting that's great
what do you want 20 year olds
to know about screenwriting
20 year olds all right it's been a
long time for me i'm 36 now so uh
okay so not everything has to be a
video game or a comic book in movie form
those are great but not every movie has to be like
and they're not going to buy your superhero script
unless it's from an ip uh i've made the mistake of
writing my own superhero and nobody cares because
it's not it doesn't already have the audience you
know that's where as horror you can come up with
original horror movies and it's awesome we want to
see it you can come up with awesome action movies
it's original we want to see it don't don't write
adaptations there's a don't write adaptations of
things you don't own the rights to and second
don't write an original superhero movie because
nobody cares unless it's an adaptation
it's a very oh interesting thing yeah so
if you can get the rights to a superhero by all
means get the rights and then write it but don't
write your own superhero and don't try to writing
that adaptation of something you don't own the
rights to i've seen a lot of people in the forums
like on facebook who are wanting to write their
own spider-man movie you don't own the rights of
spider-man no one will ever see that in fact they
may even try to sue you if you try sending it
to the people who do own their rights to it so
um i made that mistake once again when i was
first starting out i wrote a super a superman
script not knowing i couldn't do anything with it
um i wrote an adaptation of the vagina monologues
not knowing that i couldn't do that and i got
touched with people found out the rates already
owned so blah blah blah didn't work um that's
that's the thing don't don't adapt something
you don't own because you're just gonna be
disappointed and waste your time what about advice
to 20 year olds on mindset like don't get too
high or too low i think when you're younger and
you come here and everybody's so in awe of young
people in in hollywood um it's easy to really
to go on these rollercoaster rides because
people are telling you how amazing you are or
they're either telling you you're not and
then they just told you yesterday you were
right so don't let um rejection hurt you
too bad because they're not necessarily
rejecting you the person they're rejecting
your script and a lot of people seem to take um
a rejection of the script as a rejection of them
personally like like as if if because i didn't
like your script i hate you i don't hate you i
don't know you you could be a wonderful person
but i don't like your script it's not it's not a
great story i'm sorry um but it has nothing to do
with the person so don't let the rejections
be personal for you and on the flip side
don't rejoice at every minor success or something
that even looks like a minor success because it
can still fall through i can't tell you how many
times i've had this amazing looking deal that then
just gets yanked out from under me for whatever
reason you know i would i had a producer a few
years ago who was going to pay me like 20 grand
to write a pirate movie for him and then all of
a sudden his investor who was giving him it was it
was for like a like an 80 million dollar budget or
something like that and then he was like oh i have
the money blah blah i'm gonna send you the stuff
i'm gonna send you the twenty thousand
dollar check to start writing like next week
didn't hear from him next week didn't get a check
so i call him up oh yeah so my investor dropped
out um or another one where i was supposed to get
hired to write a sequel to a horror movie and then
like the producer just stopped communicating with
me all of a sudden no reason given just stopped
uh i even had one producer who literally
died during our negotiation so that didn't
happen you know so it's like there's always always
something that can make it go wrong so don't start
celebrating until the check is cleared is the the
the the rule of thumb i've got on that like i i'm
it's fabulous that people are interested in my
stuff but until like there's a contract sign and
money in my hand it could go wrong at any time and
even after then they're still playing movies that
sell for millions of dollars the script and then
the movie never comes out you know so uh stuff
dies in development hell every day you know uh
so nothing is a success until it's 100 successful
what's your favorite movie about the industry i
really like trumbo uh that was a really fantastic
movie um why did you like it aside from brian yeah
cranston's amazing in almost everything he's even
greeting that new mountain dew commercial
are you kidding me um he's fantastic seeing
how the industry was at that time is interesting
to learn there's been other movies that have shown
that like uh you may have not seen the majestic
with jim carrey uh where he played a screenwriter
who ended up getting blacklisted you know um
because they thought that he was a communist
or whatever and there's the same time period
and so it's very interesting to see how the the
all the world of hollywood is being shaped
by hearsay yeah um and then to still see
how trumbo and his friends kind of like
circumnavigated the issue in a creative clever way
like yeah they took a huge cut in their paychecks
but they still did what they love you know and
yeah it was just a really interesting look at
what the the industry was like back then
and then how people could get around that
um and how they all changed today and then
again brian cranston's a freaking genius
what's your biggest screenwriting regret that
i didn't move to la sooner i had my first
opportunity to move to los angeles in 2009 i think
it was um i was working on i was still living in
michigan at the time uh working on movie sets as
a production assistant and myself another pa and a
makeup artist we're all discussing moving out here
together um then one of them had a uh a sudden
like immediate death in the family that now they
and and so now they had to be the sole provider
for their family um and so they really okay now
i can't make the jump out to la and without them
the other person was like well i don't want to go
if she's not gonna go kind of thing you know and
so left just me and i could absolutely afford to
still come out here on my own because i had saved
up all the money from like the five or six movies
i and and two tv shows that i had paid on out
there but i just didn't i i don't know it was it
was one of those fear things where like it was a
fear of the unknown sort of thing you know whereas
like i was gonna be fine coming out here with them
as like a um like a safety net sort of thing
because at least i would know somebody because i
didn't know anybody out here and so i didn't have
the courage the film courage to come out to la
when i could have the first time and so it ended
up like losing me you know so many years because
the time i did move i was 2016 you know so now
it's like i've lost like eight years of potential
experience i could have had out here well there
was a lot of fear in 2009 because the recession
right so a lot of people didn't know still what
was going to happen and a lot of speculation so
you know i wouldn't beat yourself up over that
it was a scary time yeah sure and and it's one
of those things where you could you know you
could talk yourself up about any bad decision
you make and and make it seem like oh well it's
understandable that you made that choice at the
end of the day i wussed out i should have just
come out here um obviously certain things would
have gone differently i would have never met my
fiance okay i love you um you know and and stuff
and or maybe i would have but you know by that
point i would have been hopefully bigger by now um
but it's one of those things where like i i feel
like it was a missed opportunity that i could have
started my life much sooner i guess um rather
than you know i would would have been in my 20s
out here i could have gotten a job you know
as as like either an assistant somewhere
you know whether it be a pa on a set or being an
assistant like in an office or something like that
um but now nobody wants to hire a 36 year old
person you know as like the bottom level thing
because like the pay is like minimum wage at this
point you know it's like when i'm 20 minimum wage
is fantastic i can live on minimum wage of course
there's ramen noodles what can go wrong now that
i'm in my 30s minimum wage would kill me you know
i would never be able to afford my apartment on
minimum wage i've couldn't you know hold up my my
current standard of living and stuff now so it's
like i feel like i lost out on the chance to live
within the means that i had when i was in my 20s
rather than the means that i've procured over
the years with the experience now so i have more
life experience but it's less experience i could
have been sharing in hollywood and moving up the
ranks already so it's like i'm already starting at
square one in my mid-30s rather than in my mid-20s
well this is total cliche but i don't
know if i always believe this but this
is the cliche saying everything happens for a
reason i don't always subscribe to that and i
know it's just like can i get any cheesier
but right um if we take that and dissect it
as much as it should be like on a mug and you
know somebody in front of somebody's computer
do you think that's true or do you think
that we tell ourselves that i think it's
a combination because obviously you can't it
depends on if you believe in fate i guess um
i'm not a big subscriber in fate because it takes
away any choices i would have had i guess um so on
on on that side like it's not it doesn't work out
that everything's supposed to happen the way it's
supposed to happen because you don't know how it's
supposed to happen that's true um and you can also
if things happen in a different order you're gonna
have a different place so it's kind of a thing of
you would have a different life which life would
be better the life you would have had or the life
you do have um so i don't really know it i don't
know where i would end up you know like having
been an extra eight years in los angeles would i
now be the next shonda rhimes or would i still be
travis sepala trying to be shonda ryan you know
like um would i have a lovely gorgeous fiancee
or would i be alone or would i have a different
fiance would i be hooking up with actresses
like still wearing really well this
is a screenplay right here okay okay
you know it's um i think there's
actually a script that i just read
um it was a pilot for this current pilot
season i don't know if it got picked up or
not i think he got bought picked up the pilot
they haven't announced if it's going i think
it's still shooting i can't remember the name
of it i'm terrible at remembering titles but
it is a script that follows along this
character and he makes he the show starts
with him at like a crossroads where he has the
option of either after his graduation of either
going with his parents going with his
friends or going with this girl he likes
and then the story from there tri-sex i guess
you call it since he has three different paths
what his life would be in each of the scenarios
oh and so yeah and so the show kind of
goes along that where like it'll be like seeing
him uh you know the the path where he went with
his parents because his his dad and his granddad
were both cops now he becomes a cop and so it
follows along him being a detective now in in this
in the city the path where he went and followed
his friend is he went uh because he had graduated
with a medical license he went and just you know
became a doctor and now he's a doctor and then
the third path is he end up like opening his own
business and is living with the girl now and stuff
and all three of them have the have the identical
overall um scenario that is happening and how it's
happening differently based on where he's at so
for instance in the pilot episode which obviously
i haven't read past pilot because it hasn't gotten
picked up yet is there's a congressman who gets
assassinated that in one aspect as the cop he's
you know following the assassination and trying to
solve it when he's a doctor he actually saved the
senator so he didn't die from the assassination
attempt and then with the friend or when he has
his business order he's in the wrong place the
wrong time and he gets killed instead of the or he
gets shot rather and has to go to the hospital and
stuff and as it shows like how his life would be
drastically altered in these three choices
so i don't know where the show is going to
go from there but the pilot i was like oh my god
this is brilliant like and and that kind of goes
along with what you're saying of like you know
would it be better like was i determined was i
destined or determined to be where i am now
versus had i made the choice to come out here when
i could have it follows along that same thing as
this tv pilot of like there are different forks in
the road and each one leads to a different place
you know if you want to go with science fiction or
quantum physics and stuff you know of like
multiple parallel earths you know there's the the
multi-earth theory where the an earth exists for
every possibility so any choice you've ever made
in your life it automatically created new parallel
universes you're in the one where you made your
choice but then over here you made the other
choice and there's infinite number of those and so
i don't mean to go all quantum networks and
stuff but uh you know it's one of those things i
don't know if i think i'm destined to be anywhere
because there's so many outcomes that are possible
i don't know if i'm in the best place or if i
would have been in the best place or if they're
still best place or if what's happening well i
think we can all look at our lives and say well
if i just done this earlier but we don't know if
we'd done it earlier maybe we wouldn't be prepared
to handle certain things but you would also be in
a different place entirely and would have like for
instance i had one choice that i could have made
the choice i made was to stay in my hometown and
go to work and be a sous chef in my hometown or i
could have gone to yellowstone national park and
ben started off as a dishwasher there and worked
with the rings how would things have changed if
i would have not stayed home with my parents and
gone to yellowstone you know like who would i have
met who what would i have learned what would
have happened to me you know i would be a very
different human being with that experience than
i was staying home working in a local restaurant
so i don't know if coming to la
eight years earlier when i could have
would have made a huge impact or either for
the better or for the worse you know right
yeah i don't think for any of us we
we totally know yeah do you think a
great writer will live forever through their
work i'm gonna say it depends on the story
we remember f scott fitzgerald for the great
gatsby but he wrote so many other things that
most people don't even know exists you know he
wrote other novels he was even a tv writer nobody
could i could never tell you what episodes of
anything he wrote but i know he wrote television
uh but it's like everyone remembers him because
the great gatsby like is all prey at the altar of
gatsby sort of thing you know so but if if if he
hadn't written the great gatsby he's still a great
writer and wrote all other stuff but nobody's ever
read this other stuff so and and i also feel that
it depends how timely it is versus like
current locale i guess um stuff i write today
20 years from now are gonna seem blase and
like out of place and out of touch and and
everything you know like we're we're in in
like a field now looking at comedy for instance
stuff that is funny now won't be funny later
like you look at an old simpsons episode
from like the early 90s it's not funny anymore
and is kind of like racist in parts you know the
whole thing with apu the character that they're
apparently axing a poo completely or whatever
because people are complaining that it's races but
those complaints were probably still there in the
90s we just didn't hear them as much because the
internet has grown and people um become more vocal
on their you know and are able to have a place
to vent so like for instance when i was a kid
um me and my sister are are
big fans of a christmas story
laughed my butt off at the end scene when you know
when they're in the chinese restaurant but now
that's like the most racist scene you can imagine
basically you know and it's like it was still
racist then but it was like you didn't it was
like we didn't know better i guess as a society
and the way that we have a society have evolved
made it obsolete and crass and should not be
laughed at anymore so things from now may not
live on you know beyonce so like you could write
an amazing story but 10 years from now your
story may have zero relevance sort of thing